iing it's real
nice okay
thank you welcome everyone
um this is a meeting of the public works
and highways committee and I have the
following script to read as chair of the
house Public Works and highways
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the co9 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 and the
governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020 04 this
public body is authorized to meet
electronically these are presentations
pertaining to the capital budget please
note that there is no physical location
for members of the public to observe and
listen contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general court website the notice for
this meeting complies with house rules
and RSA 91 1- a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
27136 or email
HCS
l.st n. Us in the event the public is
unable to access the meeting the meeting
will be adjourned and
rescheduled I want to introduce the
staff that around the meeting assisting
us Brad glenland committee
research and Christopher Shay uh LBA
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call vote let us start the
meeting by taking a roll call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also State whether there's anyone
in the room with you during this meeting
which is required under the right to no
law Mr Clark if we could take the role
and I would ask ask before you do that I
would ask that all members during the
course of the day since we are totally
rem remote remain muted unless um you
raise your hand and I give you
permission to ask a question or comment
thank you thank you Mr chair
representative Graham president at home
in Bedford my wife is in the um the
house somewhere and I do have a
contractor who's doing some work in the
house so there may be
noise representative
makoni and good morning presid in my
home office uh wife dogs and working son
may pass through from time to
time representative Mills is here uh my
wife is somewhere in the house with our
two cats uh representative
suo I'm here and I'm in my conference
room
office can you hear me yes sir thank you
representative
fidi representative
Newton I'm here I'm in Rochester at my
house and my wife is in the house
sub I I unmuted I'm
here thank you representative fidie nice
to see you are you feeling better I hope
yeah yeah a little
bit representative
blazic here my two-year-old is around
and uh my husband's working in his
office
upstairs your two-year-old has an office
oh no my husband's working upstairs oh
okay my two-year-old is here she's
watching
cartoons thank you repres resentative
boards representative
boards I am here just me and my 156
pound
dog oh representative
kazinski representative
kolansky I am here home with my family I
will be traveling on the road in about
an hour and a half here and
participating through my handsfree
driving representative representative
Thompson president in my office in
colbrook representative
vandel representative Vander
Castile representative cludia here uh
present in my Claremont Home uh my
brothers in another section of my home
but otherwise I'm
alone representative Edgar president I'm
at hman Hampton my wife's in the house
someplace so is
CB representative
eel home alone in New
London representative Jack home alone
and
nashwa representative
Abbott yes I'm
along
now representative
fauler I am here at tomman Swansea my
wife is in the other
room representative Newman yes here in
Nashua and my husband will be in and out
of the
house representative
Eaton representative
Eaton representative Peterson
pres home alone in
Nashua representative
query president uh home alone in
Manchester representative
bunker representative B bunker
thank you Mr chair we have 19 members
present thank you uh represent can you
hear me now trouble
unmuting representative bunker present
my wife may pass through from time to
time thank you thank you we have 20
members repres CH thank
you um our first presentation today is
from the Department of Health and Human
Services and I believe the Deputy
Commissioner Lori Weaver is on um
commissioner you have other people with
you you can bring them up as needed to
explain what is in your capital budget
and thank you thank you representative
gam is Chris Shay on the call somewhere
I can't see him but I need his help to
get started I am um The Voice from
Beyond um yeah could you would you be
able to bring over commissioner
goule and uh from doit and Joe kisy from
New Hampshire hospital that will
complete our team this
morning so commissioner
gou okay yep and Joe kisti yep great
thank you very much this is
representative Jack I've done
those thank you representative Jack
wonderful thank you very much uh good
morning everybody and thank you for for
having us we are here to present our
capital budget for the Department of
Health and Human Services my name is
Lori Weaver I'm the Deputy Commissioner
I have with me here uh Dave weers who is
our Information Services director who
will cover all of our information system
items in detail as well as Dave clap and
Joe chisty who will excuse me be
covering our facilities issues and we
have Dennis goule commissioner G who's a
partner of ours in our efforts with our
information system so we asked him to
also be here to help us uh present today
so if we're ready to get started I will
start our slide
de okay can everybody see
that yes it's up it's up okay great
trying to adjust just my participant
view so we basically this morning as I
had just mentioned we have
um myself David clap who's our director
of facilities Dave weers uh Joe Christie
and uh Lynn wisley we actually have Mary
Kalise um Chris you may need to bring
Mary CIS over as well I I did not mean
to forget you Mary um uh as our finance
person that will be a compliment to our
presentation she should be there already
all right
wonderful okay so what we what we'd like
to do for you this morning is basically
present uh an overview of each of the
components of things that are uh in our
capital budget as well as some other uh
important items that didn't quite make
uh the governor's budget uh for both
facilities and information technology
and then talk about um them in summary
at the end um for what we're looking at
for total dollars uh basically a high
level overview is we have about three
new capital uh projects that are
associated with our buildings uh and
repairs and maintenance we do have a lot
of projects um that need attention we
prioritized three for this bium um there
are six others that we would like to ask
for consideration for as well for
facilities whereas with our Information
Services capital projects we have about
eight major projects for UT he about
today um critical projects that are uh
essential to continue some of our
services that we provide to our most
vulnerable populations um and they
they're pieced and flow together and
Dave weers will explain all of those
pieces we also in addition to the eight
we have about four other projects that
we uh would like to bring to your
attention as important requests um on
the right side is a pie chart in terms
of what we're looking at for our federal
cost for our capital budget you'll see
it's about 81% of our total cost whereas
the general funds is about
18% um so we do get uh quite a bit of a
federal match uh for our
projects so our first uh Pro uh area to
cover is uh Glen Cliff home uh and some
other pieces and I'm going to invite
Dave clap to join us speaking to walk us
through what is needed here for Glen
Cliff
home l um this is Dave Kap director
facilities for Department of Health and
Human Services uh the want Wing um is
a about 20- yearold ex uh addition to
the Glen Cliffe facility the roof on it
has deteriorated significantly um and
it's actually shown its wear um
drastically in the past year and a half
so in order to maintain the Integrity of
the building
we're looking to have that roof replaced
um it's a fairly large roof uh it's $
1.1 million as um put into the
governor's
budget see are there any questions uh
before we move to the next
slide okay seeing that I'll go to the
next slide
um New Hampshire hospital seclusion room
safety upgrad one there was a question
representative
Newman yes uh thank
you um for director from from Mr clap on
the on the um on the roof replacement
there I had asked um I'm going back a
couple years ago I just want to make
sure that whoever does the roof work is
familiar
and has seen the site that they're going
to be working on so that there's no um
surprises when it comes to paying the
bills from
estimates uh Yes
actually starting these past couple of
projects that we have done we make it a
mandatory that the any biders have to
visit the site and review the work to be
done thank you you're
welcome Mr chairman can I ask a
question who is
speaking representative
Abbot uh if you could raise your hand it
would help but go ahead
okay um is this the same Wing where I
believe it was two bium ago that they
had to replace all the
windows yes it
is okay
moving
on um the next is New Hampshire hospital
seclusion room safety upgrades there's
been a large change in a lot of the
requirements for uh the hospital and
this is uh seclusion rooms to ensure
that the client is not injure themselves
and it is um a fairly substantial
upgrade for them I believe it's five
different uh rooms that we're looking at
and um it is to put the Protections in
place to keep the um clients from
injuring
themselves see no questions moving on
New Hampshire hospital Renovations uh
comply with health and safety standards
C and D unit we're in the process of
doing enf now uh these are units that
had held um youth previously and they're
being brought up to current standards
for use by
adults um it's uh I believe will
include
um enlarging the no not enlarging but
making it uh capable of handling uh more
adults than what it presently
does this is um Joe Kirsty from New
Hampshire hospital I just wanted to to
jump in here um and uh the these
Renovations won't necessarily increase
census for the hospital um but they the
current units are really original to
when the building was built which is
about 32 years ago um and so this
project would really help us bring the
facilities in line with um a lot of our
regulatory expectations um Joint
Commission is our primary regulator uh
and uh there's quite a few facility
things that that uh they oversee and and
um these these Renovations as Dave
mentioned we're doing one on enf unit
right now um we're hoping to get CN D
unit done in this upcoming by anym uh
really improve the hospital's ability to
meet our regulatory
standards thanks
Joe if we're good with questions I can
move to the next slide representative
Graham go
ahead uh Joe while you're while you're
on here do you want to uh talk a little
bit about the the just this slide here
sure sure um I just wanted to mention to
the committee so uh this specific
project is actually in the department of
administrative Services Capital uh
budget um so uh the Department of Health
and Human Services took over occupancy
of the Philbrook building over the
summer uh we're currently running a
transitional housing program out of that
building uh but it does have persistent
sewer issues so this was just a kind of
a plug for uh from Health and Human
Services for this project that is in uh
uh Department of administrative Services
capital budget uh I believe it's a
$300,000 project um but there is a a
sincere need to fix some of the uh sewer
line issues in that building um
especially now that we have patients
living in that in that
facility any questions on uh
representative fidal
representative fi you have a question
you have to
unmute your question I'm just wondering
if this these projects you're mentioning
so
far are they not in the Governor's
budget are these things outside the
budget the these are in the governor's
budget so far okay now when when you
come to those things would you delineate
which is which when something's not in
the governor's budget so we have a clear
understanding sure yes thank you so this
on that note this slide would conclude
what was um this is in the governor's
budget for Department of admin Services
the slides prior to
which was the CN unit of New Hampshire
hospital as well as the wing uh Lamont
Wing the roof those are included in the
governor's budget but what we're about
to show you past the slide for
facilities is not included in the
governor's
budget um commissioner why don't we hit
what is in the budget before we go on to
your wish
list absolutely so we did four
facilities need um I have two sections
to this presentation the first half of
it is all of our facilities and repair
and maintenance which we just went over
so this those those items that I just
shared with you now for facilities are
the only facilities items covered right
now in the governor's budget including
the Das item
here so that would at this point
anything beyond that would be um
critical needs that are not
included and I will give you an
opportunity to talk about them later but
first I'd like to go through what the
governor has
proposed okay so I will then move on to
our Information Services um section of
what's included in the governor's budget
and at this point um to do that and
we'll come back we can come back to
what's not included for facilities Dave
weers I'm going to stop sharing so that
you can pick up on your information
slide uh so Dave weers is the director
of our information services and he's
going to pick up and cover for you what
was included in the governor's budget uh
for Information Services System starting
with our child welfare
system you were good Dave I don't know
where it went you go apologize for that
um thank you Mr chair members of the
committee my name is David weers I'm the
information Services director for Health
and Human Services and the next several
slides are in the Governor's capital
budget um submitt and starting with the
dcyf where division of children youth
and families comprehensive child welfare
information system one of one of the
things I just want to pre preface all of
these projects as Deputy Commissioner
Lori Weaver indicated are associated
with what we would call life cycle
management and it
modernization what life cycle management
is is over time systems um get old and
they stop functioning as as effectively
as they can just like your car or house
you need to maintain them in order to
provide better services to our citizens
and um in clients throughout New
Hampshire and all of these systems are
Legacy systems that are way past their
normal lifespan and we are in either
Jeopardy of federal funding um
certifications or other audit findings
that has resulted in these Capital
project submittals so so again starting
with our comprehensive child welfare
information system this system is
associated with the federal mandate from
the administration for children youth
and families Administration for Children
and Families I apologize and the current
system that we have which is commonly
known as Bridges is 23 years old it is
an it is on an architecture that is was
developed back 23 years ago and it's
actually not a common um development
platform today so it makes it difficult
for us to identify resources to maintain
the system as well as change the system
to meet Federal man federal and state
mandates associated with this Capital
project we have been working in the past
two years on the initial intake and
assessment components of this system
which allows us to bring people in
assess their needs and then move it back
into the Legacy system to do case
management reporting and then claims
processing
this Capital project will allow us to
move into years three and four of a
six-year plan to replace the case
management component and the reporting
functionality the final um years of the
six-year plan five and six would be
replacing the the the claims processing
solution which you'll find that we're
trying to marry together or braid
together with our Medicaid management
information system strategic plan and
looking at uh claims solution for the
Department as a
whole the estimated savings projected
for this implementation is um estimated
at $4 million and that's associated with
the administration for Children and
Families um surveys and estimates
regarding their their um new model for
comprehensive child welfare information
associated with practice improved
practice functionality and
processing currently we have our case
managers having to maintain the system
in multiple different places as well as
manual processes in order to manage
their their case load which is taking um
very um taking time away from their very
important um core competency of
providing services to their
clients I'll stop there to ask if anyone
has any
questions seeing none um
okay okay thank you so the next several
capital projects are associated with our
Medicaid management information system
and I wanted to put a slide up here to
just give you a background as what is
that Medicaid management information
system and what is the history of that
system so you understand the complexity
and the the different components that we
need to implement um associate with the
capital project to meet the new
strategic directions as well as maintain
the life cycle of that that program so
that system uh was designed in 2005 and
we contracted through
RFP award in 2007 in 2007 we purchased
the hardware and software and that was
the LA that was up until this past year
that was the last time we actually
replaced any hardware and software on
the system we went live with the system
in 2013 and certified in 2015
now certification is an important
component for the State of New Hampshire
as well as other states in that when we
certify the the Medicaid management
information system our federal Partners
increase their Federal match from a 50%
to a 75% of the maintenance and
operations of the system it takes
anywhere from 18 to 24 months to certify
these systems and it's a pretty large
dedicated effort to meet all of the
standards that our federal Partners
require of our
system the key benefits of the system
that for our organization is is and for
the citizens of New Hampshire is that
one in seven of our of our um New
Hampshire residents are taking advantage
of or not taking advantage or leveraging
the mmis or Medicaid Program and this
Medicaid Program integrates with all of
our common systems so across the board
it integrates with our division for CH
children youin family system our elderly
adult care system our child support
system our eligibility system as well as
our data warehousing um
environment it is a key component for
our federal claiming and funding
match it it actually has 30,000 PR
providers enrolled in the system and on
a annual basis it is processing $1.8
billion of
claims we as a result of many different
um requirements from our federal
Partners we continuously enhance this
this environment and the primary
penalties that we're we're seeing this
this current bium and we'll see next
bium um until we Implement is our
electronic visit verification system so
in Prior in Prior bams we did submit the
electronic Vis visic verification
Capital project which you'll see in a
moment and it was not approved which has
resulted in this this fiscal year we're
identifying n just under $900,000 in
penalties
and it was estimated to cost us 566,000
of general fund to
implement other penalties and risks is
we implement we are implementing the
interoperability and patient access
final rule this year in the mismis which
is associated with providing member
access to the claims information and the
interoperability with other systems our
component of that is for our fee for
service um claims processing which is
about 6% of the overall claims the
remaining 94% are Managed Care um
oranization
responsibility and then the final risk
we have of not doing these capital
projects is associated with the
certification um Center for Medicade and
Medicare Services has indicated that we
do need to have a solid approved
reprocurement strategy and and life
cycle management strategy for our
Medicaid management information system
and if we are unable to update that plan
with our five-year strategy this year
they theyve indicated that they may need
to pull our certification from our
system which would result in an
estimated $6.6 million in increased
general fund
impacts so going from this slide we have
several projects that are in the
governor's um um Governor's recommended
budget um for Capital and the first one
starts with our mmis life cycle and
reprocurement
strategy so essentially what we have
identified is two things we need to
maintain and operate the existing system
and that existing system given that has
not been maintained and has deferred
maintenance over the last 13 years um
now 14 years we have to invest in our
servers and our storage and the other
technology infrastructure as well as
come up with a 5-year reprocurement
strategy to replace that architecture
with current um current functionality to
improve our our services and reduce our
costs as part of that five-year
reprocurement strategy in this Capital
project we we have identified it
identified um the $90 million or 9
million general fund to start with a
Provider Services call center care
coordination and system integration
components of of the mm the Medicaid
management system and then begin to
continue onto other modules like our
claims processing which is the core of
the system I'll stop there for a moment
to see if there's any questions on the
mismis life cycle and reprocurement
I do have one it's representative Graham
um you talked about this being a
multi-year what's the risk if future
General courts don't approve uh
continuation thank you Mr chair and
members of the committee the risk of not
continuing this Capital program would
require us to maintain and operate the
Legacy system in in conjunction with the
the new modules as we Implement these
new modules they will interoperate with
the existing Legacy system so that we
would be able to continue processing
medic claims however we would not be
able to realize all the benefits of a
new system until we've completed all of
the
modules thank
you Mr
chairman I see no other
questions Mr
chairman representative
Thompson I I have asked people to use
the electronic raising hand and the I
can't see everybody with the slide up so
if you could help me with that I would
appreciate it representative Thompson go
ahead I don't have a hand showing on my
screen for whatever reason sorry um on
the previous um slide you showed us it
showed the procurement of the
materials
um in 2007 and it went live in
2013 it took six years to implement this
new process
with the materials she bought in
2007 thank you representative Thompson
Mr chair it did take six years to
implement in in there was many different
reasons um some of them were Federal
mandate changes to the system as well as
this the Medicaid management information
system is the most complex system that
we have um for the department and a
common implementation across Most states
is anywhere from five to eight years to
implement an mismis back when it was
what they call a monolithic um approach
where you basically instead of doing
modular which you see at the bottom of
the slid Provider Services claims
processing system integrator instead of
breaking them up into pieces um the
previous direction from our federal
Partners was to do it all at once which
required all the integration of those
components and all the project
management of all those components to
work together and and would go live at
one point in time that was the primary
reason for the delay for six-year
implementation
plan follow up Mr uh
chairman follow up um so if we give you
the $4.6 million we asking for for the
current updates how long will it take to
implement
those and if
we if we do this are we running um
are we running old software by the time
we get it
implemented you understand what I mean
um thank you representative Thompson um
could you clarify the $4.6 Million
number for Me Maybe I'm looking at the
wrong
one I'm looking at the government's
Governor's budget this the one we're
talking about is 9 million in general
funds it's 10% of the total cost
okay all right I'm
mistaken but I guess my question is by
the time we get the software and
implement it is it out of Co out of
date that is a very good question
representative Thompson and Mr chair
the pretty much any time in technology
the minute you implement it it is old um
however the the newer technology new
strategy of modular procurement along
with some more technical components of
how it works
is leveraging um I would say maybe
commissioner goule could help me with
this conversation but however it would
say it will be deprecated however it
will be on current current development
platforms and so that we can continue to
scale and sustain the system whereas
right now the the the current solution
that it's running on is seven versions
old of Oracle and IBM products which is
no no longer supported by our vendors we
would be on the current version of all
of those supported project products as
well as the current Hardware so our
vendors would continue to support the
system which is a key component of
certification with CMS as well as when
we update to the current what normally
happens with most of our vendors is they
support what it's called a n minus1 or
nus 2 current version minus two versions
so they'll let us continue to support
that 45 to 10 year
period okay thank you very much
representative eel yes thank you and
thank you Mr weeders for being here um I
think you know we have a copy of the
governor's budget and then we have a
copy of um your requests and so I'm just
trying to align what I see in the budget
to your requests I see the mmis life
cycle
management um is 35 million that was
your priority five I see a total maybe
you're getting to this and if you are I
can just hold up but I see your total
request is 90 million so maybe some of
your priorities are aggregated in that
number that's a very good question
representative eel and Mr chair um our
original request was for 35 million for
the life cycle management of the
solution and that 35 million will
essentially take all of that Oracle and
IBM as along along with several other
software vendors and up update them to
current technology as well as upgrade
the hardware to the current technology
so that we would be able to maintain it
for the next five years while we are
also doing a reprocurement strategy so
subsequent to our request we we um met
with the governor and addressed our mmis
strategic plan for reprocurement over
the next five years and he added to his
go his recommended um cap toal budget
the additional 55 million so that we can
start on that reprocurement strategy so
that we're not here next by Anum asking
for another extension of of life cycle
Management on a legacy uh system so the
idea there is that at some point in time
you you in it you look at a system and
say is it old enough to be replac
replaced and you look at that and
balance it say how much does it cost to
maintain
and operate the current system and what
are the impacts toward the the customers
or in this case the clients and the
citizens as a result of that older
technology we've identified a 10-year
life cycle for most of these large
systems to get a return on the
investment is all as well as indicate
say we're going to leverage the
technology for 10 years and then replace
it with the current technology so that
we could use it for another 10 years so
that not only do we improve the
processes internally for our staff we
also improve the services that we're
providing um both from a self-service
perspective
leveraging um newer Technologies like
text messaging to people having web um
apps that are on their phones as opposed
to having to go to a a web page on a
computer those are some of the new the
nuances of newer technology that weren't
available back in
2007 so that's what that additional 55
million or 5.5 million in uh General
funds would fund and we were planning to
start that with our Provider Services um
component our call center component our
care coordination component and system
integrator as well as you'll see other
capital projects in in the the next
several slides to address some other
components of the mmis to include our
federal
reporting um and our electronic visit
verification
I would point out that right now the
committee is focused on what the
governor has proposed whether we keep
that and then in our work sessions and
executive sessions we will look at any
additional requests that may or may not
be able to be funded in the current bium
so I need the committee and uh the
department as they present to keep that
in mind so that we are not getting
confused with we want an extra 5 million
and assume that it is part of the
governor's
budget thank you Mr chair to be to to
clarify the this mmis life cycle
management and reprocurement is in the
governor's budget the full 90 million
and it is item number eight on the the
PDF document that he
submitted okay moving on
so the next project associated with the
Medicaid management information system
is our federal reporting integrity and
compliance um Capital project again this
is part of the governor's recommended
budget and this is key to maintaining
our federal match associated with u
updating our CMS 64 report which is our
report that is used for submittals for
federal financial participation and that
is the key report that we need to submit
quarterly on time in order to continue
our federal matching um
funds additionally it's going to address
our current issues associated with
claims adjudication for encounter
claimes as well as our Pharmacy benefits
management reporting our tmis reporting
and then as we implement the electronic
Vis verification system it will need to
integrate into our federal reporting
strategy it would in it would integrate
here as
well this platform has been implemented
over the last several years and we
continue to grow and and expand it so
this particular project is not a 90 90%
federally funded project as a result of
our goal to have one single Enterprise
business intelligence platform where we
bring our data together to be able to
effect effectively Not Duplicate efforts
across our different divisions this will
reduce our our costs overall as if we
did it the the original direction we
would have seven or eight of these
different platforms and Implement these
seven or eight different times on
different systems that integration is
planned to bring in our Behavioral
Health System our New Hampshire hospital
data into the system which has already
begun as well as continue the
integration between our children youth
and Families Our eligibility system
child support service as and long-term
supports and
services it it also will continue in to
enhance and extend the system to support
the master client index which enables us
to basically leverage the economies of
scale of one system and connect to it
from our other from our various Case
Management Systems within our Divi
different divisions within our
department and then the final component
is the final component here in enhance
and extend is our data governance or
metadata management and data management
which is in is important to adhere to
federal and state um privacy and
security rules to ensure that we are
sharing the data with people that need
to have access to the data and that
we're able to log who has had access to
it and report on that information as
well as well as continue the data
Integrity which means keeping it
um keeping it consistent and accurate
for when we report the data
out I'll stop there to see if there's
any questions on
this seeing
none and then we have our electronic
visit verification system and again as I
stated earlier in the in the testimony
this is associated with a federal
mandate it is the 21st century cures act
which was signed into law in December of
2016 originally it was required for all
states to have this implemented by
January 1st 2020 however many States
including our our own requested for um a
goodfaith e effort exemption to January
1st
2021 hoping that we would identify the
funds to be able to implement it prior
to that deadline unfortunately we were
unable to um identify those funds
through either Capital submissions or or
um operating submissions and we were
unable to implement that system by
January 1st 2021 the center for Medicaid
and Medicare Services has indicated that
they will be um imposing a penalty on
our personal care services initially for
the fiscal year 2021 and in count and
future fiscal years in the amount of of
0.25% in 2021 which equates to about
$860,000 um for this this bium and then
will increase over time to include the
Home Health Service um penalties if we
continue to not Implement an electronic
visit verification system this system is
gold
at um reducing fraud and being able to
post payment recruitment but basically
identify U what's happening so what it
will do from a process as you see on the
right of the slide is the provider
arrives at a client home they
electronically check in to say that
they're actually at the at the Home in
the residence it will do a GPS
verification that they are there they
provide the services they record the
services and then the visits are
basically confirmed prior to billing and
this will help reduce fraud and automate
that process um Most states not all
states but Most states have implemented
this system we will be one of very few
that have not at this
point our funding request for this
amounts to a 566,000 general funds which
I just want to note that that general
fund impact is less than what our
penalties will be if this if this
Capital project is not
approved any questions on I do have a
couple of questions when you were
talking about uh fiscal years you were
talking uh Federal fiscal years for
example we're almost halfway through the
federal fiscal 21 so no matter what we
do we're got to pay that for this
year thank you Mr chair you are correct
we are paying an $894,000 or
$864,000 penalty estimated penalty this
this fiscal year and then next fiscal
year or 2022 we anticipate that penalty
to be 1.3 million and that would be our
state fiscal year um penalties not the
federal fiscal year penalties and if we
we being the general court and the
governor approve this in the capital
budget will we be able to get an
exemption for the following fiscal year
because we've shown good faith effort
that we will be implementing this
program thank you Mr chair that that is
correct actually the way um the center
for Medicaid Medicare services will be
effectuating the penalty is on a
quarterly basis so the if we are able to
implement the electronic Vis
verification system by April of 2022
which is our our goal date at this point
if we were approved starting in July 1
to move on the project then we would not
be penalized for future quarters and so
it would reduce our penalties in the
next bium
thank
you and the the last project associated
with the Medicaid management information
system specifically is our beneficiary
service
improvement and and this again is part
of the governor's um budget
recommendation and this specific one
will address many different components
so there as we go to repr procure a
system we are required to have an
independent verification valid ation
contract which is essentially is a cont
a third party contract to review and
report on the activities that we
Implement in the Medicaid management
information system and that report goes
to the Center for Medicaid Medicare
Services essentially is an audit of all
of our activities for enhancements to
the system and it's required for us to
have in order to continue a
reprocurement
effort additionally we would be
implementing um update third party
liability um claims for for fraud and
fraud detection system that we're
working with our our um our division to
address that from a quality assurance
and in in a program Integrity
perspective the the other components of
this would be to improve um self-service
functionality as well as maintain our
federal financial participation funding
to M to keep our system in compliance
there's so there's several different
components of of this Medicaid system
that require updates and this is why we
actually pulled them into several
different capital projects to associate
them specifically to those components
and then you'll see that we have a few
other items listed at the top here and
then some other functionality that we've
been trying to implement um associated
with the Medicaid system to to manage
Nursing Facility cost reporting as well
as as well as Nursing Facility cost
analysis to support our rate
setting is there any questions on this
project which is estimated at
$800,000 in general funds or and will
have a 90% Federal match uh for a total
fund of 8 million representative
Abbott thank you Mr chairman um could
you tell me in your conversations with
the governor
um in his budget proposal this is his
number
one uh concern well you're
11 uh can you tell them tell me why the
discrepancy I I I apologize
representative Abbott I couldn't hear
your full
question asking why the the governor in
his budget has this as the number one
priority
and and
your request it's the
11th thank you oh okay yeah thank you
for the question uh representative Abbot
the the items on the governor's budget
are not in a priority order they were
just in there as
listed I believe they're they're
actually in alphabetical order they are
in alphabetical order in the government
okay thank you we will show a slide at
the end which shows our priorities order
the
items I okay to move forward
representative go
ahead so moving away from the medic
management information system capital
projects now the this this specific
project also in the governor's um um
submitt is what we call the what what is
called the minimal acceptable risk of
security and privacy controls for
exchanges or Mars e is what we call it
it is a requirement from our federal
partners for us to have this audit of
our integrated eligibility system which
is is as it say states in the name
integrated with our mmis but it is not
directly a Medicaid inter Medicaid
management information system component
it is a separ separate system it is our
second largest system that DHHS runs
and in order to maintain that we have a
requirement to do this audit every two
years which takes an estimated 12 months
to complete we Outsource the funds um we
Outsource the solution to to our um
Partners to be able to work with us to
complete this this audit and this
assessment and Remediation and the
reason why we do that is not only do we
do the assessment but we actually have
to re remediate the issues prior to
submitt to the the center for Medicaid
and Medicare
services this allows us to retain our or
75% match matching dollars for the
maintenance and operations of the
integrated eligibility system also
called New Heights and the funds
requested here is estimated $600,000
we've we have completed these several
times in the past and the general fund
expenditure for this is $60,000
any questions on the Mars
e see
none this next project the developmental
Services Information Technology
remediation project which you'll which
um members of a of the house division 3
will hear more about u in the long-term
supports and services um presentation on
Monday is associated with the long-term
supports and services Bureau of
development developmental services and
directly as a result to a
2016 LBA audit finding and what they
what they found is that the system was
unable to meet um the requirements that
we that we have both at the state and
the federal levels and that we need to
update this system from the current
process which is on a legacy I would say
spreadsheet and access database
environment into modernized version of a
web-based information system to address
those federal and state
regulations we we did begin this work
with an existing Capital project and and
we have been working in conjunction with
the integrated eligibility team and its
system and leveraging components from
that as well as this next phase will
leverage the work accomplished on the
division for children youth and families
um child welfare comprehensive child
welfare information system current well
using the Salesforce platform to
continue that work and instead of
duplicating the effort we are able to
leverage that platform forward and
continue to use that platform to reduce
our overall
costs I'm going to go ahead and stop
there on this one but the if from a from
a funding perspective this is again
anticipated to be a fun fed by our our
center for Medicare and Medicaid
services Federal Partners at
90% and our general fund impact would be
1,327
833 this one has a very specific number
as a result of us working with a
thirdparty vendor to do an assessment of
the system and provide us a scope of
work of how we can move forward and we
have um very good number uh very good
anticipation of what this one will cost
to implement in the timeline to
implement is within the next
bium see no
questions and then we have also in the
long-term supports and Services Group we
have a capital project requesting
funding to replace the Bureau for
developmental Services direct billing
solution another access database system
that has continuously
um unfortunately um failed in the past
requiring a lot of effort from our our
department of Information Technology
Partners to support us in our time of
need to continue this system forward and
is a direct association with our
corrective action plan um that was
provided to us to that needs to be
implemented in order to maintain our
federal funding for services that we
currently have that Federal funding at
$181 million this system has objectives
to basically work with the mismis and
make make changes to that system which
would be included in the mmis life cycle
and reprocurement strategy but also
update its billing processes update the
service authorization um components with
the area agencies that they support and
and coordinate with as well as eliminate
manual processes that are
currently
um currently ending in error and
requiring duplicate effort as well as
inaccurate
reporting
the the funds associated with this is
another is $100,000 in general funds and
with a 900,000 Federal funding
match any questions on the BDS direct
billing seeing none uh thank you that's
the last of what is currently in house
bill
25 um commissioner you want to continue
on with the um information
technology and then go back to the
facilities as long as we're on a on a
rooll on it I will mention that um other
agencies have come in with with multiple
additional requests and the fact that um
we are limited in what we can give right
now the requests total almost as much as
what the governor has proposed so and we
haven't heard from the University or the
community college system so we will
listen we surely do understand your
challenge I can appreciate it I I I
agree representative Graham that it
makes sense to continue on with the uh
additional request for information
services and then we can hop back to the
facilities so Dave if you want to walk
us through that
especially since we're tired up
commissioner goule as
well so the the the other important
information technology requests that we
had submitted that did not make it on to
the governor's budget um
recommendation um the first one here is
associated with our Bureau of elderly
adults Services System modernization it
would be continuing to evolve that
system which is a 23y old system um and
it needs to be updated to a web-based
service um and be accessible externally
it currently isn't ex externally
accessible requiring us to basically do
reports send the data out to our
external partners and then have them
provide the data back to us so that we
can incorporate in into the
system this system is used to manage the
the elderly and Adult Services Bureau um
social worker case loads and the adult
protection program service authorization
provider payments um related to that
Social Service block
grant over the last 10 years the the the
bureau's model has evolved to include a
higher percentage of field work by
social workers and and we subcontract
with service link personnel and
contracted agencies to associate to do
this work and not having a system that
is accessible off off site has resulted
in duplicate work where they're actually
doing a manual process for their case
notes and case information and then
having to go back to to the state
Network to upload that data into the
system and and act and then report on
that from from a perspective of what we
need to do with the case management
nodes without the upgrade the new
business practices will not be able to
be supported in additional Personnel in
order to maintain the work would need to
be identified to continue to to actually
meet the demand for the case
loads the estimated U funding on this is
2.7 million in change for um federal
funds and it was a larger majority of
General funds of $4 million and
change and then this second one on this
slide is interoperability and
integration we as part of the um cares
act we we began an implementation of uh
Clos Loop referral system to improve our
care um coordination to our services
throughout the state that closed loop
referral system is gold at um
integrating our community based
organizations Our Community Mental
Health Centers our federally qualified
Health Centers hospitals as well as our
education and juvenile just Justice
systems and then migrating into our
Managed Care Organization so that when
you have a referral for services no
matter where you're at you can get a
referral through informed consent in a
hipa compliant environment so that we
can actually provide improved and faster
um services to our individuals as
opposed to the current manual processes
resulting in a delay of those Services
um and as well as in additional to this
the New Hampshire hospital was along
with the Department of Health and Human
Services was looking for uh Time Track
tracking and scheduling system and in
specifically for New Hampshire hospital
we were looking at acute um care time
tracking which is a very specific need
that is not met by the current time
tracking system allowed um at the state
level and the the funding for this was
identified as a 33% match for General
funds at 2.6 million um 800 2.6 million
in change uh is there any questions on
this these two projects
representative
Newman yes thank you um on for the uh
Department priority number 13 for bullet
number four how many additional
Personnel is estimated could be required
if um if you don't have an
upgrade any any
idea I what what I will do
representative Newman is I will reach
back out to our division director and
identify what those numbers are and make
sure I have that answer for you okay all
right I would ask that you reach out
soon um like by next
Wednesday thank you representative Grant
Mr chair I will certainly have that that
update by next Wednesday I would
anticipate having it to to you by Monday
provide it to Mr Shay so that he can get
it out to everybody absolutely thank you
Mr
chair and then the LA the last two um
important it requests I got
representative evil well I can wait
until until he's done but um and this is
backtracking a little bit am I right
that the BDS that uh direct billing that
was included in the governor's budget
wasn't on your priority list or maybe
it's just not in the book that we
have I will need to check that but I
believe the BDS direct billing was
should have been on our priority list it
pro it probably excuse me it probably
was but we only have one through 11 so
and
I okay I I will validate that and have
that answer to Mr Shay as well thank
Mr Shay you add a comment thank you rem
Graham so back in June when the um
Governor's capital budget hearings
occurred that was on their um priority
list that that BDS direct billing was
Project number
five it did not make it into the um
Capital improvement book that you all
have the blue book where you see the 11
projects uh listed that the governor had
further work done on um with the Bureau
of um public works or
doit so in fact the the Health and Human
Services had a total of 25 projects that
they requested back in June and there
was a document that I sent to you
several weeks ago which was a summary
document of of all those um
requests and I can resend that to the
committee today if they need
that I'd be happy to
thank you I would too yeah I'll I'll
resend it then yeah thank you Mr Shay
representative
Abbott yes um I'm showing that is number
11 in the
government of serves direct
billing um I think that we covered that
that it is there and that these are in
the governor's budget just um
alphabetically and not prioritized by um
the department or the
governor yeah but it it is
there that's correct see any no other
questions on these two okay okay thank
you Mr chair the the last two projects
that we have are um surrounding Public
Health requests for their ability to do
lead U lead poisoning prevention as well
as um analyze water in for for pasas
specifically so this first one
Environmental Health Data System is to
request three Antiquated homemade access
databases um and five linked Excel
spreadsheets that have caused some some
challenges with data integrity and
accuracy and replace it with a
comprehensive Environmental Health Data
System that will take care of the data
management storage associated with
healthy homes and lead poisoning
prevention program so this current
program is running on those access and
Excel spreadsheets and it it's really
outgrown um that homegrown system and we
are estimating um a $250,000
investment in a web-based
application would bring us into U A
system that not only has the ability to
meet the lead poisoning prevention
program but also address the current um
data accuracy in Integrity components of
that system and then this last one the
pasas Environmental water testing
equipment is a request to purchase a
liquid chromat chromatograph or and mass
spectrometry system for for um water
testing in minor
renovation this in minor res renovation
to the public health lab space so to
allow for that testing the purchase of
the instrument and this renovation will
allow the New Hampshire Public Health
Labs to um effectively test
environmental samples specifically water
for
past I have a question about that last
one last year the legislature
um approve $50 million for pfas um
remediation can you not tap into that
for
$430,000 I I will um seek to see if we
can do that representative
Graham thank you it just I would hate to
duplicate efforts since that 50 million
is out hagging out there
and that that would bring me to the end
of the information technology um
additional requests so I would pass this
back to you I have another question from
representative
eel thank you um so if I read uh that
priority number 25
correctly who's doing the testing now or
is there a lot of it being outsourced or
how is that
working currently if the if the public
health lab was requested to do the
testing they would need to Outsource it
to a third party and pay for that to be
done elsewhere um I believe maybe
commissioner gulay do you have
additional information on on
that or or Deputy Commissioner Lori
Weaver what I can do is I I will also
research that to get it I can't hear
them
I don't have any additional information
I don't know if you do commissioner
gou what I what I will do M
representative eil is I will follow up
with our Public Health Labs and ID and
validate my statement and and also
address that to Mr Shay as
well thank you um commissioner Weaver
shall we go back to facilities
so Dave you want to stop sharing your
screen unless you want to scroll back
nope okay sorry that's okay so you'll
you will see that we have these other
items as 25 so as was mentioned we
submitted in June 25 uh items for
approval and we we received approval on
11 so the other items are what we're uh
sharing with you um this morning so
so we left off here at the um the
Philbrook site uh I'm gonna ask Dave
clap to um come back to us to to talk
about these were priorities 9 10 and 15
in our list that didn't get approved by
the governor's budget but do have a a a
request to be
considered if as you go through I we
have several new members so if you could
at least talk about where
these um facilities are would be helpful
sure Dave are you on the line yes I
am
the priority number nine that we had was
uh syc roof Bond roof replacement that's
at the um cunu Youth Center the old YDC
property these are the external build
bus um to the syc the sununu center
itself um that were used for support and
they were still used for some support
now storage and uh some programs the
bond roof has well P passed its useful
life it has been leaking for a number of
years and we've been trying to get this
replaced um at least four years that I
know
of the it is actually to the point that
the water is migrating interior to the
building and will be starting to cause
structural damage to the the bond if it
is not taken care of soon we are
requesting
$325,000 uh all of that General funds
for the repair and replacement of the
roof uh the next priority number 10 is
again uh the bond boiler replacement
this boiler handles again is at uh the
syc shuna youth center and handles all
the external buildings from the actual
use Center itself um there's I believe
eight buildings that are receive heating
from the U boiler at the
bond uh it had a uh problem with a power
fluctuation shut down and froze um and
is no longer
serviceable um the next is at the Glen
Cliffe um home up in Benton New
Hampshire this is the same location that
we're looking at the roof for the Lamont
building uh the Glen Cliffe wastewater
treatment site has it own wastewater
treatment system the system is failed uh
we are
in um getting close to having violations
from Dees for groundwater
contamination uh because of it so it it
is
a priority as as far as we're concerned
and trying to get that
addressed and just as I said we have uh
several new members on the committee
what is Glen Cliffe just so the people
know Glen Cliffe is a uh facility that
was originally used for tuberculosis has
been turned more into a um nursing home
for people with um acute issues as far
as
um uh let me see Alzheimer's um and so
forth
thank
you any questions on uh any of these
three
items yeah I I have one representative
Newman yes thank you going back to uh
Glen Cliffe if the system is is
determined to be failed right now how
long reasonably is it before um uh there
are going to be citations and penalties
and whatever ever how long does that
take that's a good question the we're
working to maintain the system and keep
it from getting to the point of being um
penalized by Dees on that uh we are not
at that point yet but I don't know how
long uh we can continue to do
it it could be a year it could be four
years I'm we're just we're working to
try to maintain it and keep it in in a u
moving forward
fashion all right thank you you're
welcome representative
Thompson representative Thompson you
need to unmute to
ask um with respect to the um Wastewater
system what type of system is there
currently it's called a fielded system
they have it's a buildup of sand as a
filter medium and the over the years the
filter medium does build up with solids
and U we do treat for that and that's
where we're at now it's it's the bed has
broken down to the point that we it's
requiring a lot more service to maintain
it and keep it
operational follow up Mr chairman follow
up um is what are you going to rep try
to replace it with must have something
in mind if you've got a $1.2 million
figure yes see what we're looking at
doing is replacing the full sandbed uh
the receiving system coming from the
facility the uh treatment tank the
pre-treatment tank before it goes into
the
field okay okay thank you very much
thank you representative eel thank you
Mr chair um Mr clap recognizing that we
have constraints on what we can budget
is
there is there a way that we could help
with this by perhaps appropriating a
little more do you need engineering
money is
there I know you want it all but is
there a a halfway house in in any way
here we visit the place I have some
sense of it yeah um it's it's hard to
say I mean that cost is an all-in cost
for engineering and so forth we have had
it looked at multiple times and it does
get inspected by Dees on a regular basis
um we we're working to try to keep it
functioning as long as we can um that's
the best I can say I mean it really
needs a full replacement
thank
you see any no other questions on
[Applause]
Ms and I I think for the for the next
two I'd like if Joe Kirsty could speak
to the uh next
two sure um so again I'm Joe kisy the
CFO for New Hampshire hospital uh for
priority number 16 New Hampshire
hospital security system upgrades uh so
this is a a project aimed at trying to
improve
uh staff and patient safety on the units
um we currently have uh you know
multiple units in the hospital and each
one of the units has its own uh unique
security system bought at a different
point in time uh all of those systems
are are quite outdated we actually had
one uh fail this past year um and we
couldn't find parts uh so we had to
replace the uh the entire system uh so
this would help replace a lot of our uh
kind of uh camera and surveillance
equipment throughout the building um and
then also include um a a new
communication technology for staff uh so
the hospital on an annual basis um uh we
have about I'm looking at our statement
of appropriation real quick here uh we
have $970,000 a year budgeted for
workers compensation claims um and uh
this is really an attempt to try to help
reduce some of those
um employee related injuries who might
be at the end of a hallway no great way
to communicate to their peers uh this
this type of system would allow us to
increase communication uh up and down
our corridors uh for for staff and
patient safety um so that's priority
number 16 um any questions on that
one see none
okay uh priority number 17 New Hampshire
hospital flooring upgrades uh so the
again New Hampshire hospital was built
in 1989 a lot of our Furnishings are
still original to to that date um
additionally we have a fairly extensive
amount of carpet in the building uh and
uh which really is not great from an
infection control standard perspective
uh and regulations are increasingly
going more towards not allowing uh
carpets or other types of fomite
surfaces to be inside a healthc care
facility um we do anticipate that will
also uh uh be uh further pushed um now
that the covid-19 pandemic has happened
um fortunately in this past year um we
have been able uh or or we hope to be
able to use some covid-19 money we the
hospital received to replace some of our
flooring um and so this would be uh just
the remaining portion of
[Music]
that see any no questions
great and the last one we have here is
the demon demolition of the Wilkins
building I think Dave is still on the
line
yes um the Wilkins building is located
on the senu campus down in um Manchester
the building suffered a catastrophic
fire about six years ago and has been
deemed um
structurally
um reduced so in working with public
works and the State Historical um they
have agreed to allow us to have that
taken down the building is in extreme
disrepair and it's unstable uh there are
sections of the building that could
collapse we have cordoned off the area
but we do get um
local uh youth that violate that fencing
and do get into to the area we try to
keep them away from there as much as
possible and that's why we're calling it
a safety issue we do not want to see any
uh Bu from the area getting
injured see no questions on that
commissioner I I have a overall question
on the last two
slides if we were to begin to look
at um funding anything additional in
your facilities request these are the
priorities that you would want them to
do be
in yep I'm just trying to catch up with
you
there U my computer's moving very slowly
it's uh starts with the barn roof
replacement
and yes so this slide here so the the
prior slide to that is is I think it was
asked prior about the order it is you'll
notice it is different than the order of
the governor's budget this is uh our
priority for the 11 that the governor
has approved and the very last slide
here would be the other important
requests um and I do not believe
that I'm not sure if these are Mary or
do you know if Mary kiss if you're still
on the line if these are in priority
order I do not know that they are or not
in order of
priority okay commissioner I would I
would ask that you redo that slide and
send it to the committee in priority
order um so that we can see if there are
any additional funds
available um what we could or could not
um fit into it rather than us looking at
this list going oh I like number nine or
not um number nine you didn't even talk
about really really
um correct so I can absolutely do that
for you I will uh make sure that that is
in a priority order and then send it
over to Chris and on your very first
slides you showed um a breakout of
general fund
versus um Federal funding how we
leveraged that but you were at the 145
million figure with that uh pie chart
could you send us one or send me one at
least that shows it um at what the
governor has
proposed in case you don't get any more
money
certainly thank
you and I think that with several people
at least one on here would like to ask a
question while we have all of your your
staff there
about the proposal for the forensic
psychiatric hospital that is compl
contained in two different bills and two
different bodies of the general
court sure yes I understand there was a
little bit of confusion about the
difference between the the number of
beds um what is that correct that what
you're
referencing that is correct one one I
believe says 25 House Bill two says 60
60 correct so last bium uh this was
obviously uh something that was a big
discussion and was put into the budget
we were required to do an assessment and
look at what the current need is and at
that time uh we assessed the need at 60
beds uh what was funded in the budget
was 25
beds so that is the difference between
where we were at uh two years ago and
what got funded so we now have that
discrepancy it is the
intention to build out a facility that
will uh ultimately uh be able to
eventually house 60 so it is the
intention to build a facility that will
house 25 uh have 25 beds uh potentially
with the first floor and then to be keep
the infrastructure to build potentially
a second floor where we could fill the
remainder of those uh beds getting to
six but not fill them right now because
we won't have the money to do the fill
full build on that but we will have the
money to do the fill full build on the
uh on the first floor for the
25 I
would suggest you you look very strongly
at that in the future build another
floor I I know that another agency has
been talking about building a third
floor under their facility for many
years and we still haven't got around to
it um so just look at if you get the
money the money in House Bill 2
sufficient to do the complete building
or is it only
for um the 25
beds that is what we're in the process
of revisiting since two years has gone
by and we're working with D and Public
Works to look at the money that's
appropriated on the 25 does the 25 uh
it's ultimately we have 8 million in
this budget right now uh and the 17.2
the 1725 and hb2 would be the 25 million
for the 25 beds or how much further
beyond that can we go hb2 does allow us
to uh bond out if and borrow money if we
need to do that extension to be able to
to do that build if we don't have enough
money and yes we know that there is the
potential to bond that um it raised some
concern among the members of the
committee that this committee was not
involved in any of those
discussions um just so that you know I
have asked uh Finance as they go through
house bill to to provide a um an
amendment to that that would require
your department to report to the the
Capal budget overview committee on the
progress of that that um project
regardless of the fund
Source
okay thank you for that heads
up any other questions that you have on
Capital I have a question from
representative fideli
unmute down there there found
it I was just curious if this with all
these technological advances in the
systems is it going to require a net
increase or net decrease in
Personnel in the
budget that's a that's a really good
question thank you for the question and
Dave you I'll turn that over to you
first
thank you for the question um
representative Mr chair um most of the
technological advances are actually gold
at keeping the current staff as it is
however like in the mmis group we have
been running v um six vacant positions
um to support that system and which has
resulted in a delay in actually being
able to um enhance those systems and
additionally with all the additional
projects for the Medicaid management
information system we we are seeking
additional positions for that um in the
I think it's two positions that we're
looking for for that and in funding to
manage those projects once those
projects are are over they would be able
to maintain the existing systems as it
goes forward but to be more clear the
technology is goal at taking manual
processes and um not and not
overburdening our existing staff and
addressing some of the delays that we've
resulted in those manual processes so
that we do not have to add additional
Staffing um commissioner weaver or
Deputy Commissioner Weaver did you have
anything else to add no I think you
answered that thank
you representative
Thompson you have to unmute Denis
okay
sorry um Mr waiters uh I guess my
question is back to the it um issues and
the penalties that we've been assessed
by the federal government do you have a
total of what those penalties amount to
in the LA I guess it would begin at the
last beginning of the last bium up to
current
um certainly representative Thompson Mr
chair uh the current penalties are
actually associated with electronic
visit verification they have not been
enacted on us yet so we we anticipate
seeing those that first penalty um at
the end of this month um from from our
federal
partners and and then every quarter
after that we would see those penalties
so that
$860,000 of estimated um um penalties
would be quarterly each so one in one
for January through March of this fiscal
year one through April through June and
then continuing every quarter after that
um there are no other penalties that
we've seen um what we have been
indicated by our our center for Medicare
Medicare and Medicaid services is that
what what's called an advanced planning
document it's the document that we need
to submit to our to CMS to indicate what
we're doing with our
mismis that expires the federal funding
for that system expires June 30th and we
have to resubmit a document showing how
we're funding the life cycle management
as well as the reprocurement strategy
for the system by June 30th with um with
our approved strategy in order to
maintain our certification of that
system so those again would be feature
bium next next bium penalties if they
enact those penalties on on
us follow up Mr chairman follow
up um in the beginning of your
presentation you referenced the $900,000
uh
penalty that may have already been
assessed thank you representative
Thompson I
didn't so I may I may have Mis misspoken
what what I'm indicating is that we are
already non-compliant with electronic
visit verification for the months of
January February and now beginning of
March and until such time that we
Implement an electronic visit
verification we will be penalized at
that 0.25% for this for this Federal
fiscal year and then it will go up to 1%
of our personal care services costs
which we estimated for this fiscal year
at 864,000 and it it may be more or less
depending on our our final reports to
them um and so when I indicated about a
$900,000 penalty that's what we're
anticipating for this fiscal year
regardless if we get the funding for
this Capital project um at this time we
would not be able to implement
electronic visit verification system um
to meet that January 1st 2021 deadline
to avoid that
penalty I apologize as I took my note
um I wrote the 900,000 down and then the
864 under it I didn't know they were the
same figure roughly they are they are
roughly the same figure represent
than thank you um I'd like to go back to
the spu just
to understand a little bit better so um
so the total amount that you're
anticipating the building will be is 25
million um so so there's 8 million
roughly that was appropriated last year
I guess that was carried over that's my
understanding and now what's in hb2 is
7.25 million and it's anticipated that a
decent hunk of that is going to come out
of fed funds I wondered if you could
talk about the federal fund aspect of it
because to the extent that it's not
covered by federal funds I think we'll
be looking uh increasingly at our
bonding capacity for it so since we're
the bonding Geeks here any Enlightenment
you could share would be great I may
need to turn to Joe kisti in terms of
the federal I I don't I'm not um in
terms of the billing and how we would do
that uh or for the patients I'm really
not clear on that I know that for the
building we were appropriated a a set
amount of money um we asked for a
certain amount we got budgeted the 25 to
build with the 25 but in terms of the
future in the federal Joe might be able
to better address that than I
could um sure I think um that is a a
question that I I might have to um
connect with a few folks uh within HHS
and try to get you an answer back um in
terms of billing for the facility it's
uh it's it's dependent uh upon uh kind
of final design and so forth uh as to
whether or not um
it it kind of meets a certain level of
standard that can be built for so um I I
don't have a great answer for that but
we can certainly um uh connect amongst
the department and uh and send some or
submit something to uh Mr Shay uh for
the committee um followup Mr chair
followup I just want to say one whatever
you prepare for us I am sure that
finance will be asking the same
questions right I mean that's basically
what I was going to say say I think this
is probably an evolving discussion and
so you know I I think based on what the
chair said as well if you could keep us
surprised because things start end up
getting put in the capital budget that
we aren't really weighing in on that
much and we just really are responsible
for overseeing it my other question is
simpler where are you planning to build
this the magic
location um at the time that we were uh
looking at two years ago uh was here in
conquered on the State Office Park South
Campus which is pretty uh approximately
across from New Hampshire hospital the
abutment of this between the property
that abuts Clinton Street and fruit
street so it would be adjacent to the
filberg building and um depending on
where you're standing in front of or
behind the the um New Hampshire hospital
that is about the only piece of property
uh that on left on this campus uh that
we would have any uh space to build and
as you know there's the restrictions in
this campus in terms of the historical
uh buildings and restrictions um it is
pretty much that
corner representative Jack uh thank you
Mr chairman uh Mr weers I was uh
surprised to see the number of times
that the words access database appeared
in the slide deck uh if you're like me
you know what year that came out do we
have other systems you didn't call out
in the slide deck that are that
old thank you representative Jack um
definitely we have several access
databases um I would it's too numerous
to count um managing different systems
these are the the critical systems that
we submitted so we we definitely have
lots of projects that we could submit
what we what we did is we submitted our
our priority and most critical items
that are addressing the services
directly right now and what we're trying
to do is with these bigger platforms is
replace multiple access databases
that're doing many like many specific or
what I call a point solution um and make
it so that we can have a a team of
people doing many different services
with one platform so that what these um
capital projects will do is move a lot
of those access databases that we didn't
mentioned every single one into these
platforms and continue to grow um away
from access and Excel as being a systems
approach um which was the the current
process without with due to lack of
funding for these bigger S these bigger
system platforms thank
you seeing no other hands raised
commissioner do you have anything final
you would like to say I would like to
say thank you to all of you for your
time and attention and excellent
questions uh regarding our capital
budget and I will follow up with Mr Shay
on all of the items today um and uh
thank you
for having us uh commissioner thank you
and your staff for being here answering
uh commissioner goule thank you for
joining us um because there is a big
chunk of it in this and it's always nice
to know that you're in there with them
as a as a partner in all of
this um with that our next presentation
is not until
11:30 the committee will stand in recess
until 11:30 when we'll hear from police
standards and training
Council thank you
and doing this fully remote I don't know
how to put something up that tells
people to come back at
11:30 I'm calling the fourth floor about
that right now
thank you
Marty you can sit and hold a sign
John uh yeah I
could hey John if I could ask uh ask you
something
sure chairman Graham yeah I have to take
I have to uh take it an appointment
between quarter 12 and I should be back
by 12:30 so I just want to apologize for
that oh no problem I'm not sure how long
uh police standards and training will
actually take they only have one request
um and then we'll be breaking for
lunch for a longer
afternoon all right sounds good thank
you
John nice to see some my so many of our
uh members
today the proof will be when we get to
our work
sessions later in the next couple weeks
and the exec session which will be
critical I assume I'm thanking Brad for
doing
this
for
e
e e
I have
cool why is this not coming
up e
uh ladies and gentlemen can you hear me
this is director skippa yes we can we'll
be start we'll be uh you'll be seeing
the video in just a
second okay all right I didn't know if
it was a problem on my end
sorry you ready to go Mr chairman
yeah I think we are to try to get people
back and we have about one minute before
we get started back I just want to give
everybody heads up that we're about to
start
um I am back Mr chairman
Mr chairman this is representative
kolansky hi Ben hi I just wanted to let
you know that I actually have a uh a job
interview at one o'clock that I'm
traveling to right now so I will
participate as long as I possibly can
but I will have to log off to do my job
interview that's that's fine um as you
know these are being recorded and you
can catch up on YouTube
or or that way so that you won't be able
to uh completely miss
out yeah I planned on after my interview
trying to log back on if you're still
going and then catching up later on
YouTube with what I missed while
talk uh when you look our last
presentation is at 2:15 so we'll
probably still be
here okay thank you very much
the time being 11:30 I call the public
works and highways committee back into
session and our next presentation is
from the police uh training and police
standards and training Council and I
believe the
director is on with
us welcome director go
ahead uh thank you sir uh I apolog
olizee my video is not working
apparently um can everyone hear
me we can hear you
excellent
uh yeah it's it it appears that the
problems on my end and I apologize um so
I'm going to just begin uh uh chairman
Graham and committee members thank you
very much uh for the record my name is
John skippa and I am the director of New
Hampshire police sers and training and
I'm presenting two Capital Improvement
project
requests uh in the uh first request is
titled the AC replacement project and
the second one is the range ventilation
and filtration upgrade replacement
project in this request we are asking
for authorization to spend up to
$190,000 to be paid uh by the general
fund to replace eight AC units installed
in
1983 and an additional
$400,000 from the general fund to uh
help us address uh range ventilation and
filtration upgrades and
Replacements the New Hampshire police s
is in training is an independent
executive branch agency governed by the
police standards and training
Council and we are established under RSA
106l I report directly to a 14 member
Council and it is their job to set the
rules for hiring and educational
standards for every single police
officer uh in the state of New
Hampshire as of June 15
2020 there are
3,118 full-time police officers
1,151 part-time police
officers 428 Corrections and 78
probation
parole officers that we certify here in
the state of New
Hampshire we historically conduct three
16we full-time policey every year two
14we part-time
policey and three nwe Corrections acms
each
year we are also the uh Prime
source that provides inser training to
all incumbent
officers in fiscal year 2019 the council
offered 55 different in service training
courses and 12 online
courses the services that we provide are
delivered with the help of 21 full-time
and five part-time employees which
include Law Enforcement Training
Specialists who are police officers that
are responsible for uh the actual
delivery of training as well as clerical
staff and building maintenance
employees our staff is assisted by a
number of volunteer adjunct
instructors and a small number of
contracted
instructors we operate a 77,000 squ foot
training facility located on 20.8 S
Acres of grounds across from
nhti let me speak to the first project
uh titled AC
Replacements the AC replacement request
is to replace eight air conditioning
units installed in
1983 and which cover several training
areas inside of our building to include
a uh vertra
simulator uh computer lab a number of
training classrooms and a number of
Staff offices the replacement of these
units with modern efficient units will
greatly reduce R our energy consumption
reduce system maintenance costs and will
move the agency towards the goals of
reduction of fossil fuel and cost
reduction set forth in executive order
number
2016-03 this project will decrease the
state utility
[Music]
consumption the second project is the
Firearms range ventilation and
filtration upgrade replacement project
the Firearms range ventilation uh
upgrade and replacement project is for
our Indoor Firing Range which was
installed in
1992 our Firearms range is used to train
all full-time part-time and State
Corrections Academy recruits along with
several inservice Firearms classes that
we uh hold
annually after 28 years of continuous
usage the range ventilation and
filtration system is showing signs of
fatigue and the filter frames are
warping and sagging the ventilation
system must work at Peak efficiency and
Effectiveness as it is a life safety
device that removes dangerous and toxic
particles from the air during firearms
training with live
ammunition further the range duck work
located at the back of the range which
culminates on the Tactical Center roof
is weather damaged and is causing
leaking to occur and damage to the duck
work
insulation it is unknown what the extent
of the suspected deterioration of the
fan motors are with the upgrade to a
more energy efficient ventilation and
filtration system and possible revamp of
the variable frequency drive controls it
will ensure that this life life safety
device is running at Peak efficiency and
help with the agency goal of reduction
of fossil fuel uh cost reduction set
forth in that same executive order
this project will also help decrease the
state's utility
consumption I thank you for uh your time
and your consideration and I stand ready
to answer any questions that any member
might
have I will jump in at the very
beginning because I'm sure several
others have got the same question at the
very beginning of your um testimony you
talked about
190,000 for the AC
units and
4,000 for the range ventilation and
filtration upgrade in the governor's
proposal and in the uh
hp25 those figures are
475,000 for the Air Conditional
Replacements and 850,000 for the range
ventilation
um I'm more than willing to reduce your
requests to what you're asking for in
your testimony but I was trying to
figure out which is
correct uh chairman Graham I uh deeply
apologize uh I believe that uh I'm I'm
working from a document that uh was
produced prior to my appointment here
and um it is uh uh I uh I take the
responsibility for for uh not
reconciling the numbers that are in the
present budget that's my fault and I
apologize thank you representative Jack
uh thank you Mr chairman thank you
director uh some years ago we uh gave
you money to redo the pursuit driving uh
range and I was wondering uh that seemed
to be a safety issue I was wondering if
that got finished and how it's working
out
uh thank you sir uh actually it's
working out uh very well if if you
listen in the background you might even
hear some squealing tires because
they're using it today so um it's been
um uh working out very well for us I do
think that we are looking to uh just put
a seal coat over the top of uh that
project just to uh ensure that we can
get as much life of it uh life out of it
as
possible any other questions for the
director um director if you would like
to oh wait a minute representative
Mills uh yes thank you Mr chair uh so
I'm still trying to figure out whether
or not the request is actually for 475
$5,000 for these units or 190 we've
determined that there's a mistake on one
of these Pages which one is
it uh representative Mills I I am going
to accept full responsibility for that
mistake and I would ask that um my my
testimony reflect uh the numbers that
are in the governor's
budget uh followup please yes sir
followup um then uh I take it these
eight air conditioning units which
obviously working out to be about uh50
$60,000 a piece these aren't window
units uh what what kind of units are
they that the that eight units cost this
kind of is this all for one building or
separate
buildings the um uh I'm looking at the
my uh plant uh managing maintenance
engineer who's with me now and he's
telling me that these units are uh
rooftop mounted units okay uh and they
are to address uh uh major spaces within
the building thank you yes sir Mr Shay
you had a
comment yeah just to help the committee
out a little bit the numbers that
director is referencing are the numbers
that came in in June at the governor's
capital budget hearings at that time the
governor along with the public works and
others will pick several projects to put
in that um blue book that you have and
they end reviewing the numbers or the
estimates at that time and they they
come up with a new estimate so the best
number for the estimate is the one
that's contained in the blue book is
which is also the number that's in um
Bill
25 I was just hopeful that it had been
revised again um not that I'm aware of I
the numbers high from the Blue Book to
House Bill 25 uh representative
Edgar uh thank you Mr chairman and and
also thank you for taking my question
it's kind of a general one in a way U
has to do with the filtration system or
the ventilation system were there any
tests taken which would show that there
is a is a problem with uh any any type
of violation of air quality standards at
this time
yes we uh we do periodic uh testing uh
to measure uh lead levels uh within that
that uh training
space uh for those who are probably not
familiar with uh the way an indoor range
functions uh there is a uh a ventilation
or
circulation pattern that is set up
through all of these devices so that
it's pulling all the air from where the
shooters stand and pulling that air down
towards the
target uh so as to get those toxic uh fu
does away from the the officer shooting
and captured in the ventilation system
at the Target end of the range uh to
specifically to what those numbers are
sir uh I do not have those in front of
me but I'm looking at the uh my uh plant
maintenance engineer and he is telling
me that uh we do collect those numbers
and we do have those numbers available
if anybody needs to see them if I just
do a followup uh follow up yeah yeah I
wasn't necessarily wondering what the
values were I just wondering if there
had been a test taken and if there were
violations and that was one of the
reasons that you wanted to uh to replace
the system that's all it's it sounds
like your project sounds like a good
idea I was just inquisitive that way
thank you yes
sir and that was a question wasn't it
representative
Edgar any other questions of the
director or for police uh standards and
training seeing none thank you
director thank you chairman and uh thank
you ladies and gentlemen I appreciate
your
time for the committee it didn't take
the half hour that I had thought it
might um our next presentation is not
until 1 pm and that is the Department of
Natural and cultural Affairs um so the
committee is in
recess until 1 p.m. unless somebody has
a question or comment of
me seeing none the committee is in
recess until 1 p.m. thank you all
hi
Mike Mike
Edgar Jim you talking to me
Y and Mike
Peterson thank you hi uh nice to see you
live and in person yeah thank you guys
your
concern well I was thinking about you we
kept noticing you weren't at the
meetings so I thought I'd send a little
note to
you no I'm just at the point where
[Music]
I'm trying to get rid of all the medic
the medicine they gave me get out from
under it all you know it's crazy yeah
why kids would take drugs it's beyond
me it's
scary some of these
drugs oh yeah so yeah looks like a
couple Mike's uh sent you a note
Jim thank you oh more than one Mike sent
a note to Jim oh yeah that's what it
sounds like yeah hi Mike hi
Jim and the Sue Newman was wondering
how's Jim fidy these
days well I'm alive
yeah good looking good and and how is
your wife
doing she's she's actually a lot better
shaped than I am
now she had a rough time and she's doing
well now they give her a clean bill of
health we'll keep our fingers crossed
because we still don't I'm still don't
know why she
fainted those times
and the committee is in recess if we
could stop the recording
please anyway so Jim good to see you
talk with you later you guys you
know but
uh you know some of these some of these
drugs they gave me you know I would hear
people
singing very potent I heard a brass band
playing the star spangle banner I
know hopefully you weren't hearing the
the Angels you
know
and yeah it was just crazy I
mean I've been able to get rid of two of
the
drugs and I'm working on the last
two so but I guess one of the last two
is is a nasty
one so well you sound lucid and alert
and that's a good sign oh
yeah now this operating all this
computer stuff though
is you know you have to you have to
master that mute button and I got new
stories for you Peterson about yeah
tarus I got another
Subaru and which kind which kind of
Subaru did you get I got a uh the next
one
up
Outback oh that's a great car highly
ranked highly rated and the
Whatchamacallit the cruise
control also keeps you in the center of
the
land yeah you take your hands off the
wheel and it drives down the road makes
the curves does everything then it
flashes a big red light put your hands
back on the steering wheel no
kidding well you know these cars are
getting to be really smart
it keeps you in between the white
lines so it's it's quite
interesting well good luck with that new
car I'm gonna have some
lunch yeah I'm gonna go have some
chicken
Jim oh he's gone
yes
e
e e
rep Mills can you hear
me uh yes I can I can hear
you okay thank you I was just trying to
fix the problem that made it hard for me
to respond to the roll call this morning
thank you okay no problem you got it
we will resume in just a couple of
moments at one
o'clock
e e
I'd like to call the session
of Public Works and highways back in the
session the first presentation that we
have this afternoon is from the
Department of natural and cultural
Affairs and I believe the commissioner
is already
on hello can you hear me yes we can hear
you and we have with
you um I have Tom Mansfield with me to
my left and I have uh director of Parks
and Recreation Phil
Bryce and our director of forest and
lands will be with us in a moment and
also on our screen you'll see Chris
Marino who is with us as well to answer
questions Here Comes
Patrick
um so we're one just one moment
commissioner uh Mr Shay yeah thank you
represent Graham during the lunch hour I
emailed a new presentation from the
Department to all the members and we've
updated that on our website there was
just a couple of slides that they needed
to have added to that original
presentation I sent to you so I just
wanted you to it was available
thank
you okay commissioner you're you ready I
am more than
ready I will start with a few remarks
and then we'll open it up okay
okay um thank you for having us today
it's an honor to be before you to
present the Department of Natural and
cultural resources capital budget
request for the 2022 2023 bium this is
just the second time that dncr has
presented a budget
as it only became a department in July
of 2017 when Governor sonunu took
advantage of an opportunity to leverage
connections by merging Parks and
Recreation and forests and lands with
the State Library Division of historical
resources the New Hampshire State
Council on the
Arts these five divisions share a
mission to protect preserve promote and
manage the state's natural and cultural
resources supporting New Hampshire's
high quality of life and strengthening
the experiences of our residents and
guests
the current covid-19 pandemic has only
reinforced The public's engagement with
the Great Outdoors longing for Community
connections and overall appreciation for
cultural
experiences one illustration of this
boom of support is our online donation
button on the state parks website during
the 2019 calendar year Parks received
$2,554 from online donations and so far
in the 2020 calendar year Parks has
received over
$84,000 in online
donations we're very enthusiastic about
the $4 M83 th000 allocated to dncr in
the governor's capital budget while this
is about $3 million less than the last
bium the capital Investments shown in
the 20 or the 12year summary sorry in
your packet have allowed us to focus on
much of our priorities as part of our
effort to stay in step with the ongoing
need for improvements in our
infrastructure that we are responsible
to maintain
safety is a top priority throughout our
agency and for that reason we have
placed our radio communications Network
replacement at the top of our capital
budget
needs our Statewide radio network has
reached the end of its life a reliable
radio system is necessary for critical
Life Safety Communications for this
department and our Public Safety
Partners we come to you with the full
support of the Department of Safety who
proposed this integration solution that
will allow for us to replace our entire
out-of-date system instead of only half
and this will save us save the state
money by integrating into Do's recently
installed Statewide radio system and by
sharing
resources the strong partnership between
dncr and do benefits all Granite Staters
by ensuring strong inter agency
communication next on our list is the
Mount Washington water system upgrade as
you know the summit of Mount Washington
is a very popular destination a more
modern efficient and freezeproof water
system is necessary to support increased
numbers of visitors year
round Roofing and repairs is a regular
request from this department as is
toilet building upgrades our state park
system is operationally self-funded
which means we need to attract visitors
and repeat visitors in order to sustain
operations the capital Investments that
help us tackle deferred maintenance
projects respond to emergency situations
as they arise and provide clean and safe
bathroom facilities enhances the visitor
experience and support our overall
success before we open up to questions
about the various infrastructure
projects listed before you I do want to
take a moment to preview a project that
will soon need our attention the Canon
Mountain Tramway has been one of the
most significant attractions in the
state park System since the first
version was installed in
1938 that original Tramway lasted 40
years before it was completely replaced
in 1978 through 1980 with the current
system that we enjoy
today it's now time to start planning
its next chapter to ensure the reliable
and safe operation for the next 40
years the Canon Mountain Tramway is an
integral part of our winter and summer
operations within Franconia Notch State
Park and is a major contributor to our
overall revenue
generated we have begun the process of
researching our options and we are
available to share some of our
preliminary estimates and potential
project phases with you today
the work accomplished within this agency
plays a vital role in maintaining the
quality of life that we are all so proud
of it's with the support of our citizen
legislature that we can continue to
ensure our public places are safe
accessible and positioned to bolster our
economic future through a robust and
responsible outdoor recreation economy
and a creative economy that is being
recognized as a priority in communities
large and small I thank you for your
time today and I'm joined by members of
our agency's leadership team and we are
ready to answer your
questions commissioner if you could go
over each of the product projects that
are included in the governor's proposal
and then
we'll consider the
Tramway great thank you of course um
with me is Tom Mansfield who is more
than our department architect um but he
has put together some um specific
details about each of the project
projects that we've outlined and that
the governor included in his capital
budget so I will turn it over to Tom
thank you very much the governor's
budget had four items totaling uh
5,233 th000 which includes some federal
money which is why that's higher than
the 4,000 we told you earlier but the
first item on our on our list is radio
communications Network replacement for
$713,000
the uh radio communication system is how
a lot of our field people communicate
with each other it's a an essential
system for doing for uh life safety
situations that come up like wildfires
floods storms it's also essential for
our daily operations it's how our Park
staff communicate with one another it's
how uh Mount madno organizes rescues and
how Hampton Beach organizes their
lifeguards so an essential service but
our system was put in in 1995 and that's
pretty old for radio
equipment so we can't get replacement
parts anymore and it doesn't have the
functional operations that new systems
have a new system is interoperable that
is to say if uh I'm a lifeguard holding
a radio right now I have to call a
central dispatch and then if they need
to talk to the next lifeguard down they
can relay my message to him but with an
interoperable system I can talk directly
to them and if it's interoperable
between agencies it means if I'm a park
manager and I have a real problem I can
go directly to the state police where I
can get help from fish and game so
that's what the new system would bring
us and we think it's very important to
us now in the last bium we made a
request for this same uh project and we
were asking for uh 89
$95,000 for doing the southern half of
the state recognized that the radio
system is a big cost item and we had
split it up in the two phases Southern
half and Northern half uh we were only
able to get
400,000 for this current vium and we
haven't spent that money because talking
to our radio supplier Motorola there's
no good way to peace meal the system it
has to be done as a whole upgrade so we
to this bium hoping that we could get
more funds so that we could complete the
system now on our radio system we've
been working closely with the Department
of Safety they have been helping us out
maintain all of our communication sites
and it has really been working out very
well they looked at our proposal for the
southern half of the state with
us we asked them to consult with us on
it and they came back to us and pointed
out that all of our communication sites
are sites that they already have
equipment at and that their existing
equipment in many cases could
accommodate what we were hoping to do
with a new system so looking at this
together we realized that if we be
became integrated into their system we
could really Save A Lot on
infrastructure
equipment so uh we are coming back to
you today with a proposal to replace the
entire State system for the $713,000
working with the do people their people
will do installation and help us with
maintenance on it which is a great
advantage to
us and this will give us all the
advantages of the new system the
interoperability it'll bring us up to uh
the current standards other agencies in
the state counties local are also trying
to integrate into the same system so
that in emergencies we can all
communicate
together so uh that's why we think this
one is a very important one for us and
we're we're really pleased with the uh
relationship with do which I think is
going to
be work it's going to work well and it's
going to save us all a lot of
money I do have a question on this um
I'm glad you're working with safety
because that's always a good thing um
you're asking for
73,000 is that in addition to the
partial funding you received Last by
Anum that's correct we were asking for
it to supplement the 400,000 we had
asked for before which we're asking for
a laps extension on thank
you uh shall I move on to the next one
representative
Eble thank you Mr chair good to see you
folks again it's been a while um so I
was just trying to follow the bouncing
ball a little bit are you saying that
this money is going to replace the the
system for the whole state and
all agencies are going to benefit from
it and it just happens to be in your
budget is that the way that works I wish
it was okay it's only for uh dncr okay
so because previously we had been
suggesting a two-phase project one for
the Southern half of d ncr's uh radio
equipment and then for the northern half
of the state but we can do the whole
state for our equipment under this
project okay just follow up Mr chair so
but but so is safety also going to be
benefiting from the system you're
putting in or this really is a whole I
was just confused on the
interrelationship well safety has been
directed to try and consolidate all the
state radio communic ations and uh I
think we're their first big taker so in
that sense it benefits them from getting
their program off the ground and we can
show how it can be done and demonstrate
the benefits it certainly will be a
benefit from our point of
view okay thank
you uh
see representative
Jack uh thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you uh for coming it's always lovely to
see dncr if I understand this you
sharing infrastructure things like maybe
the towers and the power feed to the
tower but you have your own unique
equipment maybe because you're on
different frequencies than safety
something like that is that a fair
characterization of where the Synergy is
yes the system uh has repeaters which is
equipment which forwards signals and uh
Department of Safety has repeaters and
we have had repeaters too but as I
understand it and do we have Department
of Safety also here no oh okay
uh their repeaters have enough capacity
so that they could handle our traffic on
their equipment because when they built
their system they intended to
consolidate all the different state
agencies so they built that extra
capacity into the system and they're
encouraging us to take advantage of
it for the for the committee reminder
that um Department of Safety
commissioner Quinn will be on later if
you want to ask ask him about this at at
that point after his
presentation shall I go ahead with the
other items uh representative cluder
okay thank you Mr chairman a question
now is this I noticed in the Blue Book
you only had a there was only
appropriated 545,000 but the governor
gave you a little more
73,000 I was curious why it discrepancy
and you think uh this is going to be
enough on top of the
$400,000 we appropriated in the last
capital
budget yes I can explain that uh the the
455 was because that was our original
request for the southern half of the
state to do it on our own without help
from Department of Safety okay so once
we realized we could do it with the
Department of Safety we realized we
could do the whole state but we would
would need an additional
713 to do the whole state and not just
the southern half of the
state okay thank you very much for that
clarification thank you Mr chairman
representative
Thompson must be muted yourself
Denis that's better Tom is this system
going to help with the emergency command
center in the case of you know a
hurricane or whatever is that going to
widen your
communication yes uh and
that the department of safety has
consoles all around the state which we
would be able to use if we needed to set
up quickly and they also have uh
essentially portable consoles so that if
we had a situation like a wild fire we
could bring that right to the site and
have the main dispatch working from that
site
so that's one of the advantages of the
new
system okay thank
you um it I just learned that the
department of safety has staff available
on this call and they're raising their
hands Sean Sean Goodman Goodman Goodman
welcome I have brought
them good afternoon uh members of the
committee can you can you hear us yes
hello uh I'm Sean Goodwin and this is uh
Josh man uh from the Department of
Safety Communications uh section where
we are currently at the track in our
Command Post uh getting ready to support
the uh super vax uh event and um
everything that you heard from Tom
Mansfield and the commissioner is is
accurate um essentially all of the
dollars that are being requested go into
the physical radio resources that the
NCR needs to upgrade to support all
their different operations whether it be
at Canon Mount Washington uh the
Southwest the forest uh the forest fire
towers and without having to spend uh
money on duplicating things that the
department of safety's core
infrastructure already
supports thank you appreciate that
clarification seeing no further
questions moving on to Mount
Washington all right our our second
priority was upgrading the water system
on the summit of Mount Washington which
supplies our Sherman Adams Visitor
Center that uh the water tanks up there
actually predate the Sherman Adams
Building they were put in 1969 their
steel tanks and they're beginning to
rust out and because they were put in
before the Sherman Adams Building they
they weren't set up to operate
efficiently with a new system in fact
their tanks are located some 320 ft down
slope from the building so we have a
situation where our new well that went
in with the building which is right next
to the building pumps the water downhill
to the tanks and then we have to pump
back up the hill to the tanks to the
building and this works well enough in
the in the summer but those 320 fet are
uh open to freezing during the winter
and we keep that building operating all
winter long we have Observatory
Washington Observatory staff there and
we have Park staff and occasionally The
Observatory has Eco trips that uh bring
in a dozen people overnight so we have
water needs right through the winter and
in order to keep the building running
right now we have to shut down the
summer season water system drain it out
and set up the new season uh system uh
every year so that's a lot of extra
maintenance so where we're at a point
where we need to replace main components
of the water system now we wanted to
take this opportunity to really improve
the system and working with Underwood
Engineers we've come up with a plan to
put new water tanks which are made out
of fiberglass reinforced plastic so they
won't rust like the current steel tanks
we would locate them uh right adjacent
to the Sherman Adams Building dug into
the fill behind the building towards the
uh Summit side of the building if you're
familiar with the site at all so those
tanks would be underground behind the
building but right adjacent to it our
new system could pump right from the
well into the building root the water
pipes through the building to these two
new 20,000g tanks one of which would be
set up with a heater and a agitator to
keep the water moving so it won't freeze
in the winter time so we would have the
same water system running winter and
summer and uh that would be a great
convenience to us and we don't have to
go through all the testing for a public
water system every time we change over
uh so it's highly desirable for us to
get this accomplished uh we thought that
that would be well our current ask is
for a million 120,000
for it there's quite a bit of site work
and any piece of work on the summit of
Mount Washington is complicated and
expensive as you may know from previous
requests uh could I answer any questions
on that
one see no
questions all right our number three
request is for roofing and
repairs uh this is a group of uh
projects that we're requesting money for
roofing repairs and deferred maintenance
required to keep our state parks open
and other state parks and other D NCR
facilities operating and providing
Services it's a source of funding to
allow the department to respond to
critical facility failures things like
water and septic pump failures boiler
failures storm damage one year we had a
a big storm in April that tore up the
parking lot in Northampton State Beach
uh we were able to get that repaired
because we had money right there we
could move quickly and get that parking
lot repaved in time to open for Memorial
Day so it's quite important to us uh
there's a attached in the packet there's
a list of repairs and there's a list of
roofing projects uh the repairs are
representative of the types of projects
that we wanted to address with this
funding but we know that since we're
dealing largely with uh situations that
come up up during the season uh there on
the emergency basis the list is going to
be subject to substitutions and
revisions in order to accommodate that
uh that flexibility is greatly important
to us so uh this year in
Roofing there's about
$340,000 worth of roofing projects we've
identified and uh I'm pleased to report
that we are coming to the end of our
deferred maintenance un Roofing the
state parks is somewhere in the vicinity
of 8 65 buildings A lot of them are very
small buildings
admittedly uh but when we started this
program of roofing and repairs which I
think was in about
2026 uh we were hopelessly behind in our
Roofing and now with this appropriation
over the years we've been able to
whittle that list down so that as we go
forward it'll be a all scheduled
maintenance in other words we know that
every two years we'll have so many roofs
come up that are due to be repaired and
that should be a manageable amount that
we can continue into the future so this
has been very useful to us to get this
funding representative Abbott for a
question I have to unmute Mike
yes just follow up on what what your
explanation was I'm assuming that these
projects will be
prioritized based on me is that correct
that's
correct and we recognize that uh
sometimes those priorities shift in the
course of a bium as different situations
develop and things we have to respond to
change
see no further
questions next
is toilet
building our fourth item was a request
for uh continuing support in our ongoing
program for toilet building
upgrades we have uh just about 85 toilet
buildings or bath houses in the state
parks and other state reservations
and uh many of these buildings have had
long hard service it leaves them
difficult to maintain and hard to keep
clean and we know from reports we get on
questionnaires that we ask of our
patrons that the quality and conditions
of our toilet facilities have a major
effect on whether our visitors have a
good experience in the state parks and
whether they're interested in coming
back so uh we have been working on
replacing any of our facilities or
renovating any of our facilities that
don't live up to to our state park
standards in this panium we had uh four
uh toilet buildings that we hope to
address and the first one was a
renovation of the of the toilet building
at the south end of Hampton Beach we did
the exterior of this building several
years back when we were doing other work
at Hampton Beach but the interior is in
a pretty rough shape at this point uh
right now it includes a lot of shower
rooms and what we've realized is that
for showers on the beach what people
really like and what works best is
exterior shower pole facilities so that
we don't have to have interior shower
rooms which are difficult to keep clean
and hard to maintain so we can do much
better uh with the interior building we
can provide more toilets and we can move
the shower poles outside so that would
be a great Improvement at Hampton South
Beach then in our campgrounds we had uh
two toilet buildings which we want to
renovate and add on to so in Pak uh it's
toilet building number two which is in
the Neils Cove area if you are familiar
with pakway uh these are buildings which
date back to the 70s uh we will renovate
the existing toilet areas add on showers
stalls uh what we call Family bathrooms
that's private bathroom with a sink and
a toilet in it and uh pot washing sinks
for our
campers uh we'll do a similar thing in
White Lake toilet building also toilet
building number two in White Lake which
is in the area one Campground so both of
these buildings would be a combination
of renovation and
addition and then the fourth building
was the uh toilet building number three
which is on the south side of Lafayette
campground at Lafayette We have replaced
a lot of toilet facilities but this is
the one building that goes back to the
1950s it's uh pretty rudimentary and and
uh well-loved but hard to keep up and is
not really living up to our camper hopes
these days so we would propose replacing
that building all
together and that's the four toilet
building upgrades that we had hoped to
do can I answer any questions on
that representative Jack yeah thank you
again Mr chairman uh the fact that these
are listed with very general things like
toilet building repair or roof
means that you can spend the money on
whatever projects you want within the
limits of the money you have and you're
and this is sort of informational that
you're giving us what you'd like to work
on is that right that's correct so uh
these are certainly the priorities that
we want to address but sometimes uh we
might get stopped on one toilet building
or another one there could be a problem
that comes up and this would allow us to
continue in the same category but uh
move on to another building until we can
resolve whatever the hold up on the
previous one for example at uh at wissow
we had have in this bium a request for
uh redoing that toilet building there
what we've realized is uh our water
supply is is not good enough we're
waiting to drill a new well to see
whether we can get a water supply uh if
we can we'll go forward if not we'll try
and use the funds in the other toilet
buildings that we had asked and that by
any representative eel yes thank you um
so the this looks like it's a 5050 match
with fed
funds is that we've been reading a lot
about
lwcf is is that the funding or and
what's going on with all of that that's
exactly the funding uh the commissioner
may be more up to date than I am with
the current state of lwcf funding
but that's the funding that we can get a
50-50 match for on projects like this
which allows us to extend our Capital
dollars quite a bit yeah and you
probably have seen a lot of recent news
about um some changes made to the lwcf
fund um the previous administration made
a few changes and it was sort of
revealed to the public um in January as
soon as we we all of the states notice
these changes
we asked our Governors and our um our
federal delegation to to please help us
reverse the changes to go back to how
we've always operated under lwcf and
that was successful so we are back to
how it's always been run and we feel
very confident that those funds are
readily available and that we can use
them in this
way follow up Mr chair follow up okay
thank you very much um I was really glad
to see that that uh reverted back to the
way it once was since you went ahead and
mentioned W Winslow were you saying that
if you can't get adequate water you're
not going to follow up on the toilet
building or I didn't quite follow what
you meant there I would never dare
suggest such a
thing we we will look into composting
toilets if that's the
case I see well I know a lot of people
that would like to have the toilet
building follow up that's why follow up
thank you um commissioner just just a
point um you handed out the the slides
and it says toilet bowl building
upgrades for 2.3 billion I know it's
only half that but when somebody just
picks up a piece of paper they think
it's it's the whole thing I I would just
break it out on all of your slides
between the two sources of of funding so
that people actually know what we're
doing thank you we
will any further questions on what the
governor has proposed and we've been
talking
about if not represent representative
eel all right well I don't comply
actually with your request because it's
not in the governor's budget but with
your for
ER I just like to ask lwcf money could
be used for the Canon Mountain upgrades
at some point or doesn't it fall within
the right
category um we're we're going to talk
about Canon mountain now um and maybe
they can answer that question as they go
through that um but looking at the
dollar amount on Canon You've Got A Hard
Sell
yes um I recognize that um uh
representative evil the short answer to
your question is yes um lwcf funds could
um work to support this effort um the
reason I felt compelled to bring this
before you today is because I wanted to
give a heads up about the future needs
at um the Canon Tramway um I I'm not
expecting um a magic wand today to fix
the Tramway um but I feel like this
shouldn't be something that is just
sprung upon you um with with a a rushed
need so I wanted to make sure that this
committee was well aware that we are
starting to do our research and come up
with a plan and a
proposal so that our state can figure
out how to move forward and support the
Canon Tramway um and so that's really I
wanted to put it um in front of you
today I'm sort of taking advantage of of
your of your audience right now um to
make sure that that you have time to
think about this that we have time to
answer your questions and that we can
think creatively about how we can
sustain such an iconic piece of New
Hampshire moving forward so um so that's
why I put it in front of you
today okay let's um go ahead and go
through it briefly um and I'm sure that
there may be some
questions great I'll turn it to you Tom
yes the uh existing Canon Tramway was
installed in 1978 or 80 we're coming up
on 40 years and we had a one of our
regular series of inspections that's
done by the manufacturer on a on a
schedule where they checked the
condition of the Tramway in
2018 and they advised us that it was
time to start planning for the
replacement of the
Tramway um it just at 40 years we're
sort of at the lifetime of it one of the
most significant problems is the
electronic controls being a 1978 vintage
they are controlled by floppy discs we
can't get any replacement for these
controls if they should
fail so the way the Tramway works is
that the uh the controls the brake
Hydraulics the carriages the hangers are
all part of an integrated system so the
guts of the tram that actually moving
Transportation tram all need to be
replaced as one
unit uh our current estimate for what
that would cost if we were to do that
now would be in the $6.5 million range
so that has to do with motor drive brake
Hydraulics it's the tram cars and their
hanger arms
it's the carriages that run on the on
the cables the gear
boxes uh all the equipment for tracking
the ropes uh the hall ropes the bull
wheels and the labor that goes into it
so it is a big package and that much
it's going to be hard for us to break
that down into phases I think if if we
get to the point where we can do this
replacement we would want to plan to do
that as one
unit uh other items that would go along
with a big overhaul of the Tramway would
include painting of the exterior steel
work in the Tramway Bays if you're
familiar with the Tramway the the bays
are 40 feet high steel structures open
where the tram cars go in and out the
steel in these things has rusted out
very much like a a Steel Bridge would
rust and uh we would we need to grind
down the rust on that and get it
repainted we actually went out to bid uh
to get that painting done not being
aware of how complicated to process this
was uh we had a budget of 250,000 and
our low bid was $1.8
Million so uh that that bid was high
because we had asked them to allow us to
continue operations while they were
painting I think maybe we would
reconsider that in another time out but
it is a big number to get that steel
work in good shape then we have the the
Tramway Towers there three towers that
support the cables up the mountain uh
the towers uh we have inspected visually
and they're actually in pretty good
shape but we need to after 40 years we
need to have structural engineer
actually go up check the Fasteners make
sure the steel isn't compromised we know
that there's some uh minor work to be
done on the foundations with the
regrouting uh so that's an item and then
of course of course we have The Lodges
we have the The Lodge at the base the
base station and the mountain station
and those were all the same vintage uh
well one at the bottom is actually older
but uh they were last they had major
work last done in the 80s and they're
really showing their age and their wear
the exterior of the building needs to be
sealed up that's the siding and the
windows and the mountain station we have
the roofing that needs to be done we
need a new sprinkler system in the base
Lodge and there are just interior
renovations to to make our new Tramway
system look like a new system and not
like one that's 40 years old all the
interior finishes carpeting ceilings
lighting all that sort of stuff for
which we put in an allowance of 500,000
for each one of the of The Lodges that
brings us up to a total of uh
12,225 as our current working estimate
and as we we know that's a big number
and uh we're working on it uh we could
do the base station Renovations a
separate
phases uh that would be one way to
spread this out and maybe ease the pain
of doing such a big
project but uh we know this is coming
and and that uh it would be a shame if
we
couldn't get this into shape before it
actually failed on us and we had to shut
down the Tramway so that's why we're
trying to get a jump on it
thank you representative Abbott for a
question yes I just thank you Mr
chairman I just wanted to ask the
question when you talked about these
controls with the floppy disc have you
consulted with the dit on
this I believe that the Canon people
have I don't know that for sure I think
that uh they pretty much throw up their
hands for a long time we had one
electrician at Canon who was able to
keep the system running so that's how
we've gotten by so far uh he's now
retired representative Faulkner yes
thank you Mr chairman um the question is
don't know if you have this information
available but could you explain what's
the difference between ridership and the
summer versus
winter and if you have the information
about other serves New Hampshire
residents versus uh people from other
states I think that might yeah help
understand thank you representative and
thank you for catching the fact that it
is important to us in in several seasons
um I'll turn to director Phil Bryce who
oversees the state park system and could
speak a little bit more specifically to
our ridership at the
tra uh good uh yes good afternoon uh Mr
chairman members of the committee uh pH
Bry director of the division of parks
and recreation in
dncr uh good to be in front of you again
two years goes fast uh the um you know
we will get you the details on that
information I don't have them off the
top of my uh head alls I can say is one
thing to uh you should know is that the
ridership in the uh summertime and the
revenue in the summertime is actually
greater than what we get in the in the
winter season so it's really not a it
supplements the skiing experience
because it gets you quickly and
sheltered in high winds to The Summit in
the wintertime which really is
nice uh on those cold days uh and then
you can have a wonderful run down the
mountain but really uh it's it's an
integral part of our uh summer and fall
experience
which is why Franconia Notch is rated
anywhere between two consistently on a
regular basis one of the top 10 20 state
parks uh in the US so it's one of those
experiences along with the Basin The
Flume um echol Lake um and and the other
the other hiking and offerings we have
there including the camping of course so
um I will get you those numbers but the
important thing to recognize is that it
really is is
a major summer uh summer uh
um uh uh what do we want I want to call
traction the regarding a winner uh
regarding uh out ofate and instate use
uh generally across this park system we
see about half half of our visitors
based on some studies but like in the
nadn is 80 to 90% out of state uh so I
anticipate that it would be a high
number whether or not we track that are
able to to know what that number is I
don't know other than an anally but
that's why I need a little bit time to
dig into that a little bit further
so representative
Thompson
um commissioner and and Tom um the $1.8
million to paint inside those
buildings it and correct me if I'm wrong
is that not not steel paneling like you
would build a steel building out
of so we're talking uh about the Tramway
Bays right and yes they're sort of
halfway between interior and exterior
because it's open to the outside and the
steel frame is exposed and that's the
part we're talking about painting then
you're correct the uh the siding on that
is a pre-finished steel panels which are
not in such bad shape uh that they're
fastened to the steel
frame follow up Mr chairman follow up
um is uh so part of the painting is not
the steel panels it's the the super
structure that's correct Y and there's
there's railings and things like that
that are also uh need to be painted but
the main part part of it is the steel
frame itself which is you know rusting
badly and needs to be ground down and
and uh re-primed and
repainted okay just seems like a lot of
money for
paint it is and I think there again uh
that that price I told you included
trying to do the work while the tram is
operating which uh on further reflection
we realize that would require quite a
bit of secondary con construction just
to protect our visitors you know walking
underneath people working up above with
grinding equipment that's a lot to ask
of a contractor and I think that's why
we got such high
numbers one more followup Mr chairman
please are
you are you going to um do you do you
anticipate the tram is going to be open
this coming
season because of the pandemic um it we
don't have a date for when we can open
it at this point
no okay thank you representative
makoni unmute yourself
Mark
Mark representative mcon unmute your
there you go now I'm with you Mr
chairman thank you for that um I have a
couple questions um so if the tram goes
down in the during your winter operation
what percentage of your your skiers what
what would that cut you back is I
imagine there's some other surface uh
some other lifts that get you there but
if you're down during the day how much
how much of your operation is uh
hindered so our tram right now is closed
due to co um we can't people into a a
closed um tram car right now because of
health concerns so we're operating Canon
without the tram this winter and
operations are great I don't know if the
director wants to add anything you can
get to those Trails using other
lifts okay I think i' heard
the I was going to say 20% but 20% thank
you I again I can get that I we can get
that in we weren't sure how far you you
all are going to go these are great
questions and we've already started
working on answering um this level of
detail uh but of course our Focus this
winter has been providing a safe uh
experience for as many skiers as we can
and we've been a little short staffed up
there so like JD is out running lifts
and those sorts of things we sent
staff from conquered to go up to help
with a list so I apologize uh usually I
like to have these answers in advance
but we just haven't been able to to get
that uh get that together so um uh what
I would say is that over the long term
it changes the desirability to ski at
Cannon when you don't have the tram
there's a big difference between uh uh
you know running up uh the the the
outdoor lift uh in a nice day it's but
running up the the the lift and then you
get off that lift and then you drop down
to a second lift at the summit to go up
through very very wonderful beautiful
experience but it can be very cold as
opposed to standing in a shelter tram
for I don't know what six how many
minutes seven minutes uh you're talking
quite a different experience there so I
think what it does is it impacts the
overall experience in the winter time
can we get can so yes the answer is yes
in the winter time could you get
by um is there other ways to the summit
the answer is yes there are other ways
to the summit uh although if that that
lift goes down which does happen you
know it's nice to have an alternative to
get people to the because skiing the top
of that mountain is absolutely
unreal uh uh it's the summertime that uh
and fall that are that are uh that you
know where we can't really replace that
experience it the same
way commissioner Quinn we'll be right
with you we're running a little over as
you figured
out oh no worries sir thank
you representative mcon you had a
followup yeah thank you Mr chairman just
to finish up so um you have a 40 40 year
old uh method of transportation to get
people to top of the mountain have you
and you don't have to tell me now you
get back another time I don't like to
delay commissioner Quinn uh what's the
price to start a fresh with something
that's more efficient HS more people or
less number of people but
new we have preliminary
numbers in the 40 to $50 million range
if we were to switch over to Gondola
cars for example that means all the uh
all the infrastructure we have built for
the Tramway couldn't be reused for the
new system like that so it's a big high
jump to do
that okay thank you I'm finished Mr
chairman now representative
Thompson just a quick question what's
the economic effect of not having that
Tramway running during the winter season
I I don't know what it cost for a ticket
there or if there
additional cost to go up the Tramway how
much money are you losing by having that
that
down
and good question uh Mr chair we again
it's hard to say when you don't we we
won't know till you know we see that
impact of fewer people skiing
Canon um so and that's why we'll get the
numbers on the number of people that we
feel that are used
that tram um in the uh winter time in
the summertime I think it's somewhere
around a million and a half or more in
terms of Revenue so um that we would
that we would uh lose so but I'll
confirm that number as
well all right thank you very much
representative fauler for the final
question on this subject all right I'm
gonna pass thanks
so got thank you Barry
um commissioner thank you you've given
us a lot to think about about the
Tramway I do have one question with the
age of this Tramway is it impacting on
our insurance
costs um for uh continued
use uh Chris Marino is that a question
you can answer right now or can we
follow up with that information
followup okay happy to do
that again thank you you have anything
finally you want to add uh commissioner
Stewart I just really appreciate you
listening to our heads up today and your
consideration for this list of projects
thank you very
much and thank you for being here our
next presentation moving right along is
from the Department of Safety
and commissioner Quinn is already with
us well good afternoon um Mr chair can
everybody hear me all
right yes great well my name is Robert
Quinn and I am the commissioner of the
Department of Safety I'm happy to
presenting for our capital budget
request to each of you here today and I
just wanted to um share with you that
I'm alone in my office on the third
floor and joining me is the director of
administration Steve Lavoy who's down on
the first floor in his office so for the
2223 bium the department of safety is
requesting funding for just one Capital
project this project will upgrade the
technology and operations at the state
Emergency Operations Center also known
as the EOC which is located in the
incident planning and operations center
commonly referred to as the IPO and
that's on Smokey be Bullard the
emergency Operation Center is activated
during natural or man-made disasters and
serves as the Hub of New Hampshire's
emergency response when activated the
EOC utilizes the emergency support
function ESF structure to coordinate a
federal inter agency support for
response to the
incidents this system promotes an
effective response utilizing all
available state federal and nonprofit
Volunteer Partners and resources to
assist on March 13th of last year as
many of you know the EOC was activated
in response to the federally declared
disaster from Corona virus and covid-19
since that time a unified command
structure was established to oversee all
of the esfs staffed by individuals from
across different state agencies
including the Department of Safety
Department of Health and Human Services
Department of administrative Services
Department of Information Technology and
the New Hampshire National guide levels
of activation have varied throughout the
response this
$750,000 Capital request is for upgrades
to the technology and overall
operational functionality of the
eocc this project will ensure that the
EOC is ready to provide an effective
coordinated and datadriven response to
disasters in New Hampshire now I would
like Steve Lavoy who's joined us to go
into uh a few more details on the um um
different facets of this project good
afternoon Steve and thanks for joining
us thank you commissioner uh good
afternoon uh Mr chair members of the
committee um so as a commissioner noted
there are three uh components of this
request um there's an Audio Video
Control rer display the technology um
integration into our conference rooms
and planning rooms and then also
Furniture functionality upgrade and so
the first phase of this would be to
upgrade the existing technology within
the audio video controller display the
current video display was installed in
2007 uh it's now it's now obsolete we've
been maintaining this to the best of our
ability but the reality is that
technology has changed since then and
the volume and the quality of the
digital information that we have
available to us and that we need during
emergency response just can't be handled
by the current system um the controllers
are shown here on the top picture you
can see that this entire section has to
do with the processing the data um and
then this is the computer screen that we
use to control the um the system as a
whole so the current system is a three
screen three projector system these are
the three projectors shown here in the
middle picture the screen itself the
screens are up here on the on the
opposite wall um as I mentioned those
projectors have limited ability to
process current digital video uh and
audio and they've become unreliable we
actually had one of the projectors fail
uh in the early months of our covid-19
response activation which required us to
scramble to purchase and install and
reconfigure a new piece of equipment in
the middle of a disaster response um the
picture quality which you can probably
tell from this photo here is not high
definition uh it makes it difficult to
see fine details in some of the data and
it's also very um it's very faint so so
depending on where you're standing
within the room uh it's it's difficult
to uh see all the data that we'd like
all the different support functions to
have access to during their
response um so obviously upgrading this
video controller and the screen package
is is important to make sure that we can
continue to provide um the real-time
data that our emergency response teams
need when when responding during an
emergency the second part of this
project would integrate that audio vi
video technology within all of the other
conference rooms um as well as some uh
other areas outside of the IPO that we
use for coordinating resources across
the state so that includes the situation
room within the IPO the governor's
office within the EOC uh all the call
center rooms various um meeting places
within the IPO including the hscm
library but then also integrating with
um the National Guard distance learning
lab uh and Joint operations center which
serves as as as one of our Coupe
locations um also Newington office space
in Newington we have related to um our
shared responsibilities over seab Brook
response and then the commissioner's
office here at the department of safety
and it's important that all these uh
areas have access to the same level of
data uh because really the the
responsibility at hscm is to coordinate
our Statewide resources for a
coordinated response and so conference
calls and videos of meetings and
Leadership level planning all happens um
at various locations and they all need
that same data that's being broadcast
onto the EOC wall um and so these
upgrades would allow us to do that
that's a gap that we currently we have
in our response uh so people are limited
to what they can access based on who's
in the room and what um what permissions
they have at that point in
time and then finally the third part uh
third phase of this project would be to
upgrade the furniture um and the
functionality of the furniture within
the existing seoc So currently there are
38 workstations that have been set up um
each of them designated for a certain
emergency uh support function
so these functions might be there's one
for transportation there's one for
health uh and medical there's one for
Military Support cyber security so each
one of these emergency support functions
has a dedicated space and um you can see
uh a picture of the entire space here
with all the different workstations and
here's a closeup of what each one of
those workstations looks like um these
have met our needs uh up to this point
um but the covid-19 pandemic brought
forward some of the limitations that we
have here one of which being um concerns
related to social distancing and more
flexibility in in these seating
arrangements and so more modular
Furniture would allow us to uh better
respond while also maintaining social
distancing if there's another type of a
public response that uh requires that
that type of um that type of response on
our behalf um right now the other
challenge that we have with this setup
is that it's common for us to coordinate
between esfs and these Furniture pieces
don't allow us to be more module modular
and allow us to combine um where where
we may maybe we need four esfs to be
working on a single project uh for three
days out of the week but they're located
at different locations across this room
um now we have to rely on conference
space and again we're talking about you
go into the conference space and you
lose access to some of the data so
modular furniture will allow us to
better respond and coordinate between
our existing folks within the EOC when
it's
activated um so that the sum of those
three projects which we would phase and
Implement in that order uh is
$750,000 um that's the total of the
requests that that we're asking um for
to be funded in the 2223 budget uh and
we'd be happy to answer any questions
that you might
have questions representative Jack uh
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
commissioner for coming uh am I correct
that the EOC has basically been
continuously activated for almost a year
since that day in March that we all
remember when we came
home a dramatic difference from uh the
way it used to be used where it would be
activated for a few days for something
and then sort of shut down well well
actually um yes so the first part you're
correct in the first answer we opened it
March 10th they have taken you know here
and there a weekend off couple days but
it's primarily been seven days a week
and um but depending on what the
disaster is kind of drives how long you
know they stay open into what I mean
we've had some significant you know uh
ice storms which had extended EOC
operations 24 hours a day but no to your
point this has been the longest run ever
in this or uh March 10th we opened it up
and they are continuing and also the EOC
has been utilized you know you know not
only on Co but other events like the
protests we've had and other issues uh
um other storms and whatnot so yes to
both
questions representative
Abbott thank you Mr
um and thank you commissioner for taking
the question we heard
earlier from the Department of Natural
and cultural
resources um that this
system um could
accommodate their emergency response
systems and I just wondered if it would
be I mean how how big could it be I mean
besides
um just natural resources and I
mean how big could the uh technology and
operations upgrade accommodate other
departments well it does now I mean so
this is this serves the entire state so
if there was an issue that impacted dncr
or do or any you know any area in the
state that's what it does so this this
upgrade here will have the capacity to
meet the needs web EOC the video
streaming so so um so no matter what the
event is this technology is required
does that answer sir so yes this will
this will if there was any issue that
dncr um required you know there was a
disaster
that would be activated
representative
eel thank you Mr chair and thank you
commissioner um I was just curious what
portion of your request was the
furniture then I have a
followup Steve do you have the breakdown
on that yeah I can I I can answer that
so I mentioned there were three phases
and obviously these are estimates um but
we were estimating breaking that up
evenly so we've got
250,000 um for each section that would
include the furniture um um if that that
might be a little bit conservative um of
of of of an amount but we want to make
sure that we do this
right followup Mr chair followup um I
just wondered in general if you consider
Furniture a capital investment or is it
more
operations yeah I think it depends on
the situation that's a very that's a
that's a good question um in this case
because of the specialized nature of
this furniture um and uh and the use in
this capacity we would treat it um a
little bit differently than say an
office set for an administrative
position within a different area of the
department so in this particular
application we we are treating this more
as equipment um than necessarily a desk
and chair set yeah and that's a great
question representative eil and I just
just to add to it too I think it is
important to tie it into this project
only because where they sit how they're
situated the equipment that ties into to
those workstations it all kind of has to
has to be pulled together to make sure
that it um that the Investments we have
in um in in number two you know line up
with with the people that have to man
the
EOC thank you
commit commissioner on that I think it
is better to have it under one our
remember one of your predecessors when
we were first developing and Staffing
and equipping the EOC he went out and
made every Department cough up money to
do their own portion of of the EOC and I
think it caused some problems with
compatibility and and the rest uh so I
think it's better to have it all Under
One Roof one project that's gr I'm
talking not necessar early the gospel
yeah well I'll tell you I've learned a
lot you know by going out and talking to
employees and one would never uh imagine
how important the correct chair is to a
911 telecommunicator who has to sit you
know what I'm saying or our dispatches
so it is a piece of equipment that you
know as as a cruiser is vital to you
know the the state troopers the um you
know the the the equipment for our
dispatchers and folks that have to man
the EOC you know for extended periods is
is is important but but thank you for
the support with
that any other questions for the
Department of
Safety seeing none commissioner thank
you uh for appearing and do you have
anything you want to add at the end here
no I don't I'm just glad that you
welcomed our um folks from uh the
division of Emergency Services
Communications that have been working
closely with uh commissioner Stewart and
dancer on the radio project so thank you
for including them and uh um and thank
you for all you're doing with your
service and uh the capital
budget you're welcome all right for
members of the committee we have
about 10 minutes before we hear from the
community college system um so we will
stand in recess until
2:15 thank you all thank you
here
e
e for
hi
Shannon hello Mr chairman how are
you I'm doing
good we'll get started here in just a
minute that's representative Jack did
you want anyone else moved over I have a
few uh someone named
Moore yes please that's Matt Mo okay you
should see a Scott Field I got that and
last but not least Ed
Smith oh no oh
yeah well it's always good to see a
former chair isn't it it
is you didn't bring all the
trustees no that would have been a
little
much and I think you all know well maybe
not Susan I'm not sure where Susan hu is
appearing on your screen but she's our
hi everybody
hello and my thought was you know if
we've got Edwin Smith who else do we
need you know Smokey will give us he'll
represent our trust as
well boy making my head
big I don't quite understand why I'm not
able to move these people
looks like all our folks are
here I don't see oh there is Scott yes
yeah you get them all Marty yes when
we're when we're ready to go Susan can
more formally introduce us all but I I
think we're all on okay the time that I
have being
215 I call a meeting of Public Works and
Highway committee back and our next
presentation is from the community
college system of New Hampshire and I
welcome what is your title now sir it's
it's interim Chancellor okay that's all
right the inter Chan thank you so much
staff yes very very important people uh
I'm going to begin by um saying I'm the
uh recently retired president of
Manchester Community College and as the
president from that place for 11 years I
want to express my gratitude to you for
all of the funds that you sent to
MCC um we used them well we were able to
really develop our technical spaces if
you haven't been on that college campus
to see the great work especially the
most recent Edition the um HVAC and
electrical building which is operating
the way that we had envisioned uh so
thank you uh and today I have with me
first I'm wearing a different hat um I'm
learning in New Hampshire that
retirement is is not a a steady state
that that you end up coming back so here
I am as the interim Chancellor uh
through the end of June so with me I've
brought my own team of experts Shannon
Reed whom I think many of you know who
is our legislative affairs person Scott
Fields who is our new chief of
operations and another face that I
suspect is very familiar to you Matt
Moore who is in charge of our capital
projects so we have uh sent you uh a
short uh series of slides I'm going to
just touch on a couple of them I'll
begin by answering the first question we
were asked to address which is you know
what what was funded in the governor's
budget in the governor's budget what was
funded was an earmark for Nashville
Community College to complete the
renovations to the engineering program
program having said that you also are
giving us the opportunity to talk about
us and what we had proposed originally
so I'm pleased to do that um as you can
see right now on the screen just a
little overview of of who we are and who
we serve we serve about 26,000 students
uh this year I think our youngest
student is 16 and our most seasoned
student is in her 70s so we we cover the
the the gamut of Ages and we do this
across the entire State of New Hampshire
as you probably know within the goal is
that within about half an hour 25 miles
any Resident of the State of New
Hampshire can get to either one of our
seven colleges or one of our five
instructional locations spread
throughout the state and we are in fact
the lowest College tuition in the state
public or private at this moment and we
function with hundreds of Partnerships
with businesses in fact we've got a few
pages just to show you who it is we do
business with and maybe the most
important piece is that we're here to
serve New Hampshire residents in fact
93% of our students are from the state
of New Hampshire next slide
Chen so in terms of our Capital needs we
have four priorities critical
maintenance as you know we have lots of
buildings across our camp
campuses we're also very focused on
maintaining our it technology uh
infrastructure and in fact that has
served us so very well through the
pandemic you've heard about lots of the
colleges and how they've had to uh Go
Remote at times and then come back on
campus and they've got to do testing and
so on our needs were a little bit
different because our students are in
and of the community so our ability to
support them through our it
infrastructure has played a a key role
and and we've we've continued on our way
to meet the industry pathway programs um
you're familiar with them probably in
automotive um I was uh betraying my
Manchester Roots before I'll also say
there's a great program there uh
connection with eversource for line
worker programs you uh actually most
recently gave Manchester money to
convert a lab to continue that program
the last week I was there they were
interviewing students for the class
that's currently in session and 150
people showed up for 15 slots so uh
there's a great interest a great need
and and a terrific program and finally
our focus on spending the money that you
give us and others as well as we can we
uh we really do want to pinch our
pennies Matt has kept us focused on
Energy Efficiency as we've gone through
again a slide that just makes the point
that we're serving the folks that are
here Shannon will go on to the next one
please um this is a slide that really
I'm I'm proudest of we are a good return
on your money and in fact we have
National standing in the success of
helping people to move by the age of 30
to two economic quartiles above their
parents for me as a parent this is the
proof that we are doing what every
parent desires which is to give their
children a better life than they've had
and your investment in our community
colleges in fact is assuring that we're
doing that uh you can see two examples
here of national ranking one for nasua
and one for White Mountains Community
College next
slide a couple of other things we
actually have the highest graduation
rate for community colleges in New
England we're still working at this and
if you see the the national statistics
you'll see that it's 36% but what what
that 36% represents is people who began
first time
full-time and then graduated within a
three-year period our students are
profoundly affected by what's happening
in the economy and in fact people who do
graduate don't necessarily graduate
within the three-year period if they
start off this full-time and life
changes and they've got to go out and
work they still keep at it with us and
they still graduate so they may graduate
on The Five-Year Plan or the six-year
plan I make that point just to emphasize
exactly how flexible we are but also how
focused we are on successful
completion um and so let's go on to the
next page and we have pictures uh so
first we have pictures of the recent
project the HVAC project that I had
spoken to you about
um we also have the manufacturing lab
and the next page you've done nursing
you've done culinary Automotive you can
see the whole range of programs that
you've affected most recently clinical
Labs um at what three of the colleges so
that brings me to talking about what it
was we had originally put together our
request for the fy22 23 budget was 16.8
million and you can see from the chart
how it is we proposed or what it is we
were proposing the first line the 3.9
million was in critical maintenance and
safety followed by a
2.7 million in infrastructure and I do
believe shennon that we actually went
back and we looked at this particular
number and we have a a revision if you
could talk about that for a moment
please we do we have a downward Revision
in in this request um when we initially
filed submitted the form it was $2.75
million in total in it infrastructure
expenditures but we found within that
some um some items that really weren't
appropriate for Capital funding so those
would those would be if we were able to
do it we would need to fulfill that
those needs from our operating budget so
we've removed that which brings our new
it request to
2.25 million and we can we have a that
is more specific to it but but right out
of the gate that's a um
$500,000 decrease in our request for
it and the third line is about industry
Pathways I had mentioned the uh NASA
engineering project the other uh project
that would be included in Industry
Pathways is some remodeling and
renovation at Manchester Community
College basically to support
Manchester's partnership with unhm and
the Army
project uh what is needed is some
additional lab space so that uh the
biology majors and the and the advanced
manufacturing Majors can have the
opportunity to learn sort of the the
cross-pollination between biology and
advanced
manufacturing um so I can talk more
about that if you have questions in a
moment the next project is the White
Mountains expansion in Littleton we're
very excited about this uh the
possibility here because the college has
been saving funds and because of some
other property that they've had that
they're able to sell we're purchasing a
a building in Littleton and what we
would be asking you for is for help to
move the very successful uh diesel
program to Littleton again going back to
when I was a president at Manchester
lots of folks that are in the heavy
equipment industry said well can't we
bring that program to Manchester it
would be more centralized for us and as
community colleges we work together and
my answer was we're not going to do this
because it's a you know it's a key
program for White Mountains but people
were complaining about the fact that you
know to get to Berlin is not as easy as
if you can zip up uh 93 North and you
can go to Littleton and
so the project that we're proposing here
is that you help us to add uh the diesel
technology program to this new site
which again I can speak about our final
proposal is uh to renovate faram Hall at
nhti this would be to convert the space
to Fine Arts currently the college
houses the program off site they are
looking to bring it back onto the
college campus the lease there is about
100,000 a year so that's our whole
proposal
and I'm happy to actually turn things
over to Matt uh to speak uh in more
specifics or to Scott uh Scott is um
he's coming to us to this uh coo
position from having been the Chief
Financial Officer at White Mountain so
we have two people who can speak in
detail about the projects should you
have any questions about them so thank
you what can we answer for you
um why don't
we talk about the critical maintenance
first if you could go back to that you
have just one huge number um how would
you break that out between Life
Safety um roofs replacement of old
fixtures
[Music]
um if you don't get the whole 3.9
million which will be a stretch sure we
understand that it's certainly a
challenging time and we are grateful for
whatever it is you can send our way but
Matt could you talk specifically about
what's in that 3.9 what are we talking
about there yeah um we're talking about
um as as um representative Graham said
some roofs I don't have it broke down
the way you've talked about it I have it
broke down by colleges and I'd be glad
to do that if uh and uh I can get that
to you uh representative Graham if you
would please because I think that will
be important to all the members of the
committee when we begin our work
sessions and executive session on hospit
25 to at least be able to look at that
and if we can give pieces it's better
than giving you nothing yeah um do you
have the um information did Public Works
pass along the itemized
list because if they didn't I
can we can we we'll we'll follow up with
that yeah follow up yeah most of our try
to pull
out most of our requests are um rooftop
units electrical units um you know and
um there are some roofs but mostly um we
um few years ago I had Consultants go
through every one of our buildings and
itemize every one of the pieces of
equipment in the uh facilities and um
these are the this request is the last
of the zero to five years that the life
expectancy of the units and with what
I'll send you is is that um that list
please do because I'm I'm trying to find
I I don't have and I may just not be
able to have it in front of me at my
house um but it's not in the the book
that went to the governor okay that's
fine I I just so you know that Bureau of
Public Works reviewed it and they got
back to me and they they thought it was
excellent of how I was so descriptive in
what um the um each project was was for
and and why it was needed so I will pass
that along for
you would you like to go on to please
other specific
yeah so uh Scott do you think you can um
describe a little bit more of our
it elements it infrastructure and this
these are these are for the kind of the
central um Foundation it Foundation that
supports all seven colleges we we we
approach the it um the it function as
one system not seven separate colleges
so this investment is for Statewide
impact go ahead Scott absolutely thank
you shanon so in the new 2.25 Million
number that Shannon had mentioned
earlier we realistically have come down
to 7 particular buckets you know four of
the seven are at or beyond the end of
their useful life and that accounts for
75% of the $2.25 million and the items
that you see on the screen that VPN
upgrade are blade servers which are both
beyond the end of their useful life
moving our back a disaster recovery
backup system which is currently housed
we have a redundant copy in conquered
and also one in Durham at the University
of New Hampshire but really moving that
into a cloud-based form uh primarily
because while our copy at UNH is on a
different utility Network should
something happened in the conquered area
cost Effectiveness is really driving
people to move towards the cloud so that
the amount of money that we have in here
for this cloud-based disaster recovery
system would essentially allow us to
reduce costs longterm and provide an
additional spot of redundancy to ensure
that our data is kept safe and sound
should something happen our load
balancers are a key component of our
internet traffic system if you will they
are kind of buffers on the front end and
the back end of the way that data flows
through our sites and what these systems
do is it allows for it certificates and
things that are more technically beyond
my ability to share with you right now
but it allows for the traffic to be
monitored and controlled as it it flows
through our infrastructure so it doesn't
bog down on the back end these units are
actually housed in Durham at the
University of New Hampshire and are at
their useful the end of their useful
life as well um we have a project with
the UPS units that Shannon has on the
slide here essentially what we're trying
to do is provide another insurance
policy for a lot of our technology
closets at all of our college campuses
and academic centers essentially what's
happening is we have key in uh resour
forces in these Tech closets that are
either on UPS systems which are
essentially battery operated generators
that will kick in should we lose power
or there's a surge and acts as a
protector for that
infrastructure what's there is it's
either missing or outdated or the amount
of hours left in the battery if you will
it's uh when you go to get a flashlight
in a hurricane and the your batteries
have been in there for three or four
years it doesn't work very well so what
this essentially this project is doing
is it has aot in us to again ensure
these it closets and the servers and
monitors and everything that's in that
infrastructure area to be safe in times
of again power surges or prolonged
outages to ensure that there's heat in
the room air conditioning in the room
things of that
nature um our alls sites ticketing
system essentially what ccsnh does is we
have one help desk that is for Hardware
software facilities and what we're
trying to do is the system that we have
is is somewhat on the older side
Antiquated and we'd like to be able to
bring it in so we can actually start
tracking things that would be useful to
know in this particular conversation in
that things that Matt deals with with
rooftop units boilers we will be able to
track uh once we get the system set up
and in place we'll be able to use some
functionality to track how much we're
spending per unit on repair costs so
we'll know if it's if a unit is needs to
be replaced because we've spent so much
on it or if there's a an ongoing issue
in a specific college so maybe it's a
wiring issue we need to take control of
so having that system implemented so all
seven schools and the academic centers
can be on one platform so it's
centralized we can monitor the tickets
we can track the expenses would be a a
definite benefit from us on an
administrative side it would also get us
out in front of ensuring that we don't
have any uh mechanical issues or
computer issues that are just we're not
seeing because we can't quantify it in
one particular area and finally our our
voice system this is something that has
been uh part of the request at least
internally for a while and it's it's
been pushed off but this system itself
is at the end of its useful life we are
tied to one particular uh vendor in this
component with the usage that we have so
what we'd like to do is to be able to go
out get into a new system that would not
tie us to any one particular vendor that
would allow us to really use use our
economy es scale and pull some levers to
try and find some savings on the actual
data usage on that
system um question from representative
Abbott yes thank you Mr chairman I just
wondered if you folks had been in
communication or consultation with the
Department of Information Technology
regarding these requests
not the time oh I'm sorry Shon not in
the time that I've been here but there
might have been prior conversations
because this budget was produced before
my arrival in this R so Shannon yeah so
this year we haven't in past years um
doit has sat in on the governor's budget
panel hearings which happened back in
the summer um so they have a a lens on
it at that point and in the past
occasionally from time of time they've
had specific follow-up questions for us
they haven't this this year our it
environment is really
not related to the states in any way um
so you know if if the oit has has
specific questions or recommendations or
anything that they wish to follow up on
uh in the past they've they have
connected with us that hasn't happened
so far this
cycle okay thank
you Chancellor on this item as well um
you've got several items that we just
discussed but no dollar amounts to any
of them other than a total um I'm
assuming that the way they're listed are
your priorities but it would be helpful
for committee discussions if there was a
dollar amount against each of those as
we go
forward we we will send that to you
representative Graham thank
you our next um next request was the
industry pathway lab Renovations and
this is what has been included in the
governor's budget partially the amount
that was earmarked in the last capital
budget as phase two of the Nashville
Community College project that the
capital budget started to fund um two
years ago so so that the first part the
top of this slide is funded the second
part which is Manchester Community
College science labs is not presently in
the governor's budget so if you have any
questions about that actually Susan is
is best suited to answer them she she
has a foot in in in the MCC Camp as
well Susan is there
anything else that you want to say about
that
project
um I I would say that it the Armory
project has been underway for a couple
of years now and one of the needs that
they've noted is the need for
technicians however until very recently
um it was was primarily about the
research side of things and when we
would ask well what do you need for
technicians because that is the middle
scale level that Manchester in
particular serves they didn't know what
they needed it's been a fairly recent
discussion where they have started to
identify the skill set that the
technicians will need to work in the
labs that Army is
proposing um Chancellor on that as far
as equipping the the lab have we talked
Army and and uh the investors about
helping to fund the equipment that needs
to go into it I know we've done it for
you know Diesel and automotive and
dental and all the rest hopefully we can
leverage some money from them for um the
equipment and other things needed Within
These
Labs um yes there the in fact there are
two faculty members from Manchester one
from the biology area and one from the
robotics area that sit on the um the
educator uh groups that are connected
with army and are are well connected I
would say that the project here is is
actually about um taking over the prep
rooms that exist in um at least three of
the rooms and essentially turning them
into lab space so there's not a it's not
so much about equipment as it is about
constructing the space so that um things
can happen there there's also a very
strong connection between the faculty at
unhm and Manchester and um in in
speaking in in having the two faculties
speak what we discovered was that what
Manchester needed to do for the students
was teach them the very basic lab skills
again is not going to require a
tremendous amount of equipment and then
there's an arrangement so that even
while there's students at MCC the
students can go to hm and do the biotech
work there but this is a a connection
the other piece of it besides the Army
part is that there's one physics lab and
as the college has expanded into the uh
more into the electrical area um the the
one lab is on the smaller side of things
and again there it is also taking over
space and expanding the size of the lab
so again not much about equipment more
about um opening up the space is and
making it so that um you know equipment
in the case of the physics lab that I'm
discussing can be shifted in and out
depending upon whether we're talking
about um University Physics or we're
talking about environmental
science thank
you if there are no other questions I'll
move
on we can of course come back to any of
this is the Littleton expansion um this
this the idea of expanding White
Mountains Community College uh offerings
in Littleton you know basically the
western part of Northern New Hampshire
um something that we've been talking
about for several years now and had a
variety of different kind of
possibilities um across our our planning
path and have found one that we think is
is really very strong and that is to um
purchase the site in Littleton that we
presently lease and that's something
that that is underway and and then to
subsequent renovate it and expand it uh
as Susan mentioned one of the primary
goals of this would be to bring the
mobile diesel um program into Littleton
from Berlin much more convenient for
industry sitting at the top of 93 um
that program draws um not just from the
North country but really from all over
the state in terms of students and from
all over the region in terms of business
partners um very strong and important
program for White Mountains Community
College if you have any other specific
questions um Scott or Susan or I can can
answer them or
mat um seeing
none has this idea been broached to
um the like mayor of Berlin and and
others that know that this may be in uh
the
future yes there there have been
extensive conversations between
President Lloyd and and the mayor of
Berlin we're very sensitive to what's
happening in Berlin and um president
Lloyd has made it very clear that we're
not looking to move out of Berlin the
issue with the mobile diesel program is
that it's a program that requires a
particular accrediation and um by moving
it to this new site or to the Littleton
site we have more
opportunities at the same time uh the
major uh program of study at the Berlin
site is in the healthc care side of
things and actually by improving some of
the spaces in Littleton we'll be able to
get more people started on Health Care
Pathways but then they would go to
Berlin so this seems to be um a program
that appeals to both the mayor of Berlin
and the head official in Littleton as
well and Scott can verify but we've had
conversations going on for a couple of
years with both entities because we want
to uh keep both towns happy
frankly that is correct there have been
constant Communications uh from
president Lloyd uh the the business
community in Littleton is looking
forward to the possibility of this
coming to fruition and and again as
Chancellor H just mentioned we've
ensured that the the city of Berlin is
not going to be left an alert and by
having this synergistic relationship
between Littleton and Berlin there will
be additional students flowing into
the city of Berlin at the
college thank you representative
Thompson you had a
question I did and and basically it's
been answered but I guess my question
was how many diesel students do you have
in the Berlin operation currently with a
followup it's in the mid
20s and how many do you anticipate
you're going to get if you move this
operation to Littleton
so part of the uh the expansion of the
program in Littleton is a 10,000 squ
foot facility that we're looking at uh
that would increase the size of the
current location in Berlin by roughly
2,000 square feet but it would be able
to be modular in its nature and what I
mean by that is nothing is going to be
permanently a a fixed to certain station
so they'll have the mo the ability to
change the modality of the space that
will allow for more students as well as
different programming during offseason
times of the year so I I I can off the
top of my head I could see the program
growing by 20% but I don't have that
number off the top of my head and I
could confirm with President Lloyd what
the estimate is on
that I will also add uh representative
Graham that um the proposal to move the
mobile diesel program is being uh
heavily supported by Milton cat um they
in fact uh lent us the expertise the
company that builds all of their sites
across the United States in fact has
looked at the littlton site and has
advised us as to what we would need uh
to construct just to indicate the the
enthusiasm of the diesel Community you
had a followup representative
Thompson yeah I just um $4.2
million seems like a lot of money to
increase your student ratio by
20% it's just my opinion but I
appreciate your
aners representative
Abbott yes thank you Mr chairman I just
wondered if any thought was given to
with the diesel portion of the program
um to putting one in River Valley
Community College in
Claremont is it seems that uh I have a
lot of complaints from constituents
about um that not having a CDL program
available to in the western portion of
the
state um as far as I know representative
there hasn't been a conversation about
that but that doesn't mean that we
cannot have one so
um while the CDL program does exist at
this moment at White Mountains there had
been one at Lakes
Region um and we're following a a newer
model in the community college system
where we're trying to
identify I'll call it a center for
excellence so actually to speak about
River Valley um River Valley is the
place where we um restarted the LPN
program licensed practical nursing and
at this point it has expanded this
semester to Lakes Region Community
College and it is uh under discussion to
expand it to White Mountains Community
College so I see no reason why we
wouldn't apply that same model to the
CDL um and um I'd like to go back to uh
representative Thompson's question for a
moment I agree with you that if we're
going to be building uh spending 4.2
million that 20% does not sound like
very much I believe Mr Fields is
referring to the degree program and and
what we are also talking about here when
we talk about CDL is a non-credit
certificate and so we see uh an increase
in short-term certificates and now back
to representative Abbott you know having
the CDL program operating from one side
and spreading to another side side is
certainly something for us to
consider I would just add that the
Litton project encompasses more than
mobile diesel program more than CDL um
the the objective for that um project is
also to be able to expand in the array
of program offerings that we currently
offer in Littleton and you can see those
in the the final bullet on this on this
slide so those those
include I I won't read the slide to you
but it includes a a lot of of additional
programming in the business field the
healthcare field um general education
that students in that in that region
could take advantage
of I may just a followup to Shannon's
comment another programming option that
we're looking at in Littleton has to do
with electric vehicles
wmcc has actually just received a grant
from a Canadian uh company to start
exploring what that would look like so
when I was referring to the
the modular functionality of the space
we're able to use the space to bring in
other programs like electric vehicles
and things of that nature to expand
short-term certificates and possibly
degree programs down the road but we've
just received that seed money to start
researching that particular Avenue as
well shall I move on moving on okay the
final element of our request uh again is
uh renovation of farum Hall it's on the
nhci campus we presently have about 500
students who take courses at a least um
least space a few miles away it's up
near the prison in conquer um these are
students who are primarily taking Fine
Arts courses but they those courses
serve a wide variety of Majors so things
like um architectural technology our
digital gaming technology some of the
manufacturing programs that really
require sort of a graphic orientation or
graphic orientation so this this project
would would allow us to renovate a
building on the nhdi campus move all of
those students back to campus which
would help us a lot and help them a lot
in terms of scheduling and then just the
convenience of being on a campus instead
of a remote location um and it would
also enable us to reconfigure that space
to meet emerging program needs because
as the college looks forward you know
there are going to be new things that
that are on the horizon that it will
need to offer and um this space is
really where those emerging needs could
be
met and we can again go back to any of
this if there's questions but we wanted
to just kind of show you the array of
Industry partners that we work with and
these are current or and or recent
Partners these two slides um you can see
all across the state you can see a
variety of different types of training
relationships that we have from very
technical um and high-tech types of
training to uh more sort of business
leadership oriented training Human
Services Health Care um we we really one
of the strengths of the community
college system as I'm sure you know is
that we are very well able to respond to
to needs and opportunities from a
variety of types of employers across the
state and really provide those uh career
those education and career Pathways for
our our local New Hampshire learners so
that I believe is everything we have
brought we're happy to go back and
revisit any of these topics or projects
as you would
like
um well I'd like to make a warm welcome
to the former chairman of Public Works
at highways who's also on here um before
I open up to questions and welcome Ed
welcome back to public works good
afternoon Mr chairman and thank you very
much this this is interesting I wondered
how these Zoom
or under the how the hearings would go
under this format it's interesting to
hear it and I I don't envy you at all
you're doing a good job but keep it up
guys you taught me most of what I
do what's that you taught me most of
what I know about doing
this you were a good student if I
remember
correctly all right enough
representative evil for a
question okay thank you and thank you
very much for uh being here today folks
it's good to see you um this is kind of
hard I don't I don't quite know how to
pose the question but of course there's
a lot of uh discussion around whether
the university system and the um and the
community college system are going to be
merged anything you want to say about
that as relates to the capital budget
looking ahead I mean I would assume that
a lot of your needs would be the same I
just want to throw it open um I just as
a committee I think we'd be interested
to hear what you had to say thank you oh
that is a a tough question to answer
representative AA as we go through this
whole process uh what I will say is that
um as you can see our our needs are um
basic and entirely tied to either
maintaining the spaces that we have or
creating more opportunities with
industry I don't expect as we go forward
with this that our needs would change uh
what I have been saying is that and
frankly this is a great example of an
area that needs to be looked at um I'm a
hearing right now from our technical
faculty you can imagine that our College
faculty and staff and students are
concerned about what it would mean to
merge and the technical faculty have
already said to me Susan you know what's
the circumstance in which our request
for you know new auto lifts for example
will measure up to the University's
request for some sort you know some type
of heavyduty research equipment so it is
an area that we will be concerned about
um you know the impact on what we're
asking for right now there there is none
these are these are things that we need
but going forward we absolutely have
questions about um what will
happen so thank you for raising it but
we still need more information going
forward well it's a tough one on a
Friday afternoon so I'm
sorry no I I you know it it's the
elephant in every room that I've been in
recently so I I don't mind you raising
it at all thank you for the opportunity
to talk about it
any other
questions um to the chancellor or any of
her staff or the member of the trustees
representative
mononi unmute
yourself um thank thank you Mr chairman
uh thank you Chancellor for being here
before I go there I'd be remiss if I
didn't say hello to my old chairman uh
Smokey there and uh no doubt about it
well trained by you uh going going back
back to the um the to the
chancellor uh in the past and I've been
away a couple years in the past uh I've
always touted um about how the people
you train um um remain in our uh in our
employe in the state raise their
families they're here uh much greater
than the uh University system and I
remember numbers somewhere approaching
90% has that been updated the last few
years do you have some idea of your
census we do we do it's at least 93%
representative and depending upon the
college we're talking about it can be
97% oh wait a minute I think I'm
answering the wrong question I'm
answering the question of who comes in
terms of who stays from what we can see
and actually we gave you slide on that
so I'm going to actually look at it it's
slide
four
so uh the percent of of our graduates
employed in the state is about
77%
overall the about 23% are self-employed
and we don't have a way to capture that
but to to the point at least 93% of the
students across our system are New
Hampshire residents we think that they
you know certainly well beyond the
77% stay
[Music]
um I I would just add this this data is
is data that we derive um with or from
Employment Security so you it's
imperfect as a measure but it captures a
lot there are certain um certain folks
it won't capture so if people are
engaged in wages that don't fall within
what employment security tracks they
wouldn't show up in that dark blue bar
um but the light blue bar you know for
instance also includes community college
students who graduate from us and then
transfer on for another two years maybe
at pmus state or Keane or UNH or sne or
somewhere else so we also you know we
certainly get graduates out into the
workforce quickly in New Hampshire
communities but we also are a platform
as you know for students who wish to
transfer
on thank you for all you folks do thank
you thank you Mr chairman you're welcome
representative Jack uh thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you Chancellor
it's always lovely to see the Community
College I'll start by mentioning that I
think it was last ter we did go on a
field trip to the uh to Manchester and
saw the new building and went through
all the old buildings so that that's a
nice facility there uh some years ago I
was advocating for trying to get uh some
space on the national airport for the
aviation maintenance technology people
so they could bring in actual airplanes
to a hanger and work on them instead of
being way over there at the community
college and we put a small amount of
money in there for that and it seems
like it's not gone anywhere if you
wanted to comment on that at all um I
just know a little bit and I don't know
if Shannon knows that's an ongoing
concern for us I know that President
Jordan is looking at the aviation
program
um I'm afraid I don't know much about it
I know that the enrollment in that
program has uh
slumped um so I will put that in the
category of representative Jack we'll
we'll get back to you with specific
information um about it and I know there
had been an effort um to move it to
either um nashwa uh to an airport or
even to um the Manchester Airport I
remember those
conversations obviously that has not
happened but I I I don't know much more
right now other than the program is
absolutely under
review okay
thanks any other questions for the
chancellor or anybody from her staff
about this
presentation see
none I understand I understand my
homework um coming out of this um we
will provide you with a a maintenance a
critical maintenance breakdown um you
currently have it by college but we'll
provide it more by by type of project or
by project um second we'll we'll itemize
and prioritize our it uh projects within
that larger request um third I have a
number of um letters of support from
Littleton area businesses and um Civic
uh leaders and organizations that I'll
provide to you for the Littleton project
um so you'll be able to see the the
degree and nature of the of the real
desire for that project to move forward
in Littleton and then uh fourth
representative Jack's question about
Aviation at nasua have I missed anything
that that folks will want from us by way
of
followup not that I can think of Shannon
but remember what I always tell
you that you'll give whatever money the
community college is asking for yeah
that's
it um but we will look at all of that um
as as you all know it's always difficult
to prioritize and add uh projects that
are not included within the the
governor's proposal and still stay under
what the
treasurer um suggests that we Bond at so
it it is a challenge and we we are up to
it and that's why we do need that
additional information that we ask for
um to see what if anything that we can
give to you because tomorrow we hear
from the university system and you could
imagine that they will be asking for um
additional funds as well I I fully
anticipate that no not tomorrow next
Wednesday I'm lasted here well we we
also look forward to a time when we can
bring you again to one of our campuses
and show you the the fruits of the of
the
consideration that you're able to give
to us in the capital budget it was a
good tour of the haac area last time and
we'd like to keep doing that we'd like
to keep many things that right now we we
can't
do and we thank you for what has been
your continuous support I understand you
a very difficult decision and I trust
that you're going to do the best you can
for us to help us support our citizens
so thank you to you and to all the
members of the committee for what you've
done for us in the past and what you
continue to do we really do appreciate
it um you're welcome and it is an
ongoing effort among all of us
over the years and
decades wonderful um with that I thank
you for coming um Chancellor and all the
members of your staff um so your
presentation is done before we close
this out I will remind the committee
that we meet again next Wednesday
completely remote again Mr Shay
uh yes repr Graham I just it's after
you're done speaking I'll I'll I'll ask
you the question or the committee okay
complete I didn't want you to end the
meeting before I get to
talk yes uh completely remote uh we will
be hearing from the University system
and
um Department of
Transportation and in the afternoon as
you will notice in the calendar which
was published last night um there is a
work session on all of the um agency
presentations uh we will begin our
discussions on their requests and what
we think we can do about it it is not an
executive session but we will start to
try to uh narrow in on what dollar
amounts we are going to work with as we
go forward um at some Point uh the week
after next I hopefully I'll get either a
room or Zoom time and actually have a
public he on House Bill
25 um this is the challenge of all of us
and it has gotten greater since um the
all of the deadlines have been pushed
back to the 1 of April so all of the
Committees are uh working on um rooms
and zoom time and the rest so stay tuned
for the the week or two after next week
um and until then stay safe and Mr Shay
always listen to you I just wanted to
let the committee know that I have a
meeting with the treasurer on Monday um
to
discuss how how they account for in
house bill to the uh secure psychiatric
unit
appropriation um as a well as well as if
there's other appropriation say I know
there's two bills in front of your
committee that you have now if they were
to be um passed without being included
in the capital budget how do they
include that towards the the recommended
number um you know of 120 to 125 million
um so I just wanted to let you know that
and then as as a result of that I can
report back or do you want me to have
the treasurer come speak to you on
Wednesday afternoon briefly just to
update you on um maybe what how they
would handle that information
I Chris I think that if you could ask
the treasury if she could be there at
12:30 or one somewhere in there right
after we get started um just in case any
of the members of the committee have
further questions of of the treasurer we
won't be long with her but it's always
good to hear from from the treasurer on
her thoughts on what it is I don't think
it's going to change much from what she
said earlier where she was talking big
numbers to change the debt ratio but
let's hear what she has to say as a
committee agreed and and again I just
wanted to um get an accounting for you
guys so that when you're looking at you
know how much you think you have for
space potentially is it different if
they have to include the 17 million
that's in the um in in House Bill
too okay thank you in her work as well
so anybody
else seeing us um this meeting of the
public works and highways committee is
adjourned and we will meet again to hear
more
presentations uh next Wednesday March
10th right in early in the morning um I
thank you all for attending um I begin
to almost get used to these Zoom
meetings